START THE BUDGET SUB SIX
HEARING. I WOULD DOUBLE DOWN
BALLOT HAVE GAVEL YOUJUST YOU
JUST HAVE TO THINK OF A VIRTUAL
GAVEL FIRST- WE'RE GOING TO
JUST REITERATE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE-
AUGUST THE BUDGET CLEAN UP
THERE WILL BE NO VOTES TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE- THESE LET ME JUST
REITERATE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PROCEDURE. SO FOR THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO WE'RE HAVING
TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING EVEN THOUGH THIS IS THE
LARGEST HEARING ROOM WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE. A FEW MEMBERS
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE DOING A
BUDGET SUB SIX HEARING HERE
VERSUS A BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING CARE- ALSO RESTRICTED
FROM THE PUBLIC. ON THE BEGINS
BUT I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC TO
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE ASK THAT YOU EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
PUBLIC COMMENT IS DOT ORG
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE AL THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING- THE RULES POLICE IN
THE CAPITAL AS WELL AS
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
JUST ONE PERSON AT A TIME THANK
YOU- WITH PANELISTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HELLO
THEY ARE APPEARING REMOTELY.
WE'VE ASKED THE L. A. O. TO
PRESENT ON THESE TRAILER BILLS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO COMMENT ON THEM. AFTER
COMMENTS FROM THERE WE'RE WE'RE
THE PERFORMANCE WE WILL ALLOW
TIME FOR MEMBER QUESTIONS. ALSO
FOR. THE COMMENT VIA PHONE WE
DO HAVE TO BECOME A BE THE
PHONE THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGH
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO OH TWO- IF YOU'VE ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE NINE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY THE
EMAIL ADDRESS IS BUDGET THE
WORD BUDGET. SUB S. U. B. THE
NUMBER SIX AT A. S. M. DOT C.
A. DOT G. O. V. AND IF YOU GO
TO OUR WEBSITE THAT INFORMATION
IS THERE AS WELL- TODAY WE ARE
HEARING SIX BILLS ALL OF WHICH
ARE FULL OF ITEMS TO OUR THREE
PARTY DEAL. FROM THE JUNE
BUDGET PACKAGE- THESE DO THESE
BILLS DIRECTLY TO ISSUES- WHAT
IS THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
REALIGNMENT. PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS THE COURT ADMINISTRATOR FEES
PROPOSAL. THE OTHER BILLS ARE
MOSTLY TECHNICAL CLEANUPS. WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A FEW ITEMS
WITH ADMINISTRATION MAY HAVE
CONCERNS. THAT PACKAGE BEFORE
US TODAY IS A TWO PARTY
AGREEMENT WITH THE SENATE ON
ALL ISSUES. AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING TO SEE IF WE CAN GET A
THREE PARTY AGREEMENT. WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- WE CONTINUE TO
PURSUE ECONOMIC STIMULUS- YOU
HEARD OF AN ANNOUNCEMENT FROM.
OUR HOUSE AND THE SENATE
TOGETHER WORKING ON THAT ISSUE.
AS WELL AS A VARIETY OF COVERED
NINETEEN OF RECOVERY IDEAS AND
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES ARE BEING
PURSUED OUTSIDE. OF OUR
TECHNICAL MARKET BUDGET
PACKAGE. WITHOUT THE LECTERN
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR CEPHEUS
THE OPENING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- LET ME
JUST FIRST EXPRESS. HOW
VALUABLE I THINK IT IS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
HEARINGS. I AM OF THE OPINION
AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT. OUR WORK
ON THE BUDGET IS AMONGST THE
MOST. VALUABLE AND- IMPACTFUL
THINGS THAT WE DO HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND IT DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES OF GETTING TOGETHER
IN PERSON AND TAKING TESTIMONY
FROM THE PUBLIC. I THINK IT'S
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE. TO EVETTE THESE
TRAILER BILLS BUT THEY MOVE
FORWARD THROUGH THE IT EVEN
THOUGH. SOMETIMES IT CAN BE A
CUMBERSOME TO DO THAT THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT SO I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR CONVENING
THE HEARING. ALSO OCCURS TO ME
THAT THIS COULD BE MY LAST
BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING AND
SO- IF THAT ENDS UP BEING THE
CASE I WANT TO LET YOU ALL
KNOW. WHAT HONOR IT'S BEEN TO
SERVE WITH YOU AND- AND- HOW
MUCH OF ENJOYED TO SERVING ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. HE WAS A PASTOR I
WAS JUST THINKING THAT WHEN I
TURNED. THE GAVEL OVER TO YOU
AND LET ME JUST SAY IT'S BEEN
A- PLEASURE AND HONOR TO WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH YOU WHILE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT- YOUR
PARTNERSHIP YOUR INPUT- ONE OF
THE REASONS WE'VE HAD
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS WAS
BUILT UPON YOUR SUGGESTION AND
AGAIN I THINK WE ARE.
INSTITUTIONALLY THE BETTER FOR
IT TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE SCOPE OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THIS PROCESS. SO
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP- WE EXPECTED YOU TO
GOING TO WASHINGTON TO DO
BIGGER AND BETTER THINGS SO
WILL DOUBLE DEFINITION HERE. IN
SACRAMENTO SO THANK YOU. BUT
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. BUT THAT WE'RE GONNA
START WITH L. A. O. OUR FIRST
BILL IS SB ONE FIFTEEN THE-
AUGUST AMENDMENT TO THE TWENTY
TWENTIES BUDGET ACT. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CAROLYN CHIU FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
PRESENT PRESENTING S. B. U. R.
ONE FIFTEEN- AND I'LL JUST NOTE
UP FRONT THAT WHILE WE WERE
INVOLVED IN THE CRAFTING OF.
COMPONENTS OF THIS LANGUAGE AND
MANY OF THE OTHER TRAILER BILLS
OR COMPONENTS WE ARE NOT
INVOLVED IN AND MAY HAVE TO
DEFERRED THE COMMITTEE AND ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- BUT
REGARDING SB ONE ONE FIVE AYE
AS THE CHAIR ALREADY NOTED
THIS- BILL WOULD AMEND THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
AND- LARGELY MAKES OUR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO THAT
BUDGET ACT UPDATING FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT SORT OF THING- BUT
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THE PROVISIONS ARE FOR THE
COMMITTEE. I IN PARTICULAR
THIS- BUDGET TRAILER EXCUSE ME
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WOULD
SPECIFY THE LEGISLATURE'S
INVOLVEMENT IN AN
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL. ON
TERMS OF THE LONG TERM CARE AT
HOME BENEFIT. NOW WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
ARE WITHDRAWING THE PROPOSAL
FOR THIS BENEFIT AND
CONSEQUENTLY BOTH HOUSES- ALSO
PLAN TO REMOVE. THIS LANGUAGE
FROM THIS PARTICULAR BILL. SB
ONE ONE FIVE ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE. THAT
WOULD ALLOW FUNDING FOR- FROM
THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM TO PAY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS FOR SPOUSE.
CHILD AND PARENTS PROVIDERS. IF
A POLICY BILL EXTENDING THAT
BENEFIT TO THOSE PROVIDERS
PASSES. WHAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIS. BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
INCLUDES LANGUAGE SPECIFYING
THE PROCESS FOR REDUCING
REALIGNMENT- BACKFILL FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR IT
WOULD PRO RATE- THE REDUCTION
IN COUNTY'S BACKFILL FUNDING
SHOULD COUNTY IS- BE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS. AND IT ALSO
DIRECTS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES TO BRING
THEM BACK INTO COMPLIANCE. WITH
THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON LEAST EMERGENCY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THE L. A. O. SUMMARIZED- THE
BILL I WILL JUST ADD A FEW MORE
DETAILS. OF SO ONE ONE FIVE
EIGHT SB ONE ON FIVE OF THE
MAJORITY OF THESE- AMENDMENTS
AND THIS BILL REFLECT TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS AND CONFORMING
ADJUSTMENTS TO ITEMS IN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY BUDGET ACT. AND
THE BUDGET BILL JUNIORS BOTH OF
WHICH WERE PASSED IN LATE JUNE
JUST AN ADDITIONAL- THINGS TO
NOTE THERE ARE A FEW GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATIONS. THERE'S A
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND INCREASE FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WHICH IS ASSOCIATED WITH A
FOSTER CARE FUNDING. AND THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS TO CALTEX AT CAL
EXPO TO SUPPORT EXISTING CORE
OPERATIONS FROM. SERVICE I
GIVEN THE LOSS OF REVENUE AT
THAT THEY SUFFERED WITH THE
PANDEMIC. ADDITIONALLY. SOME
NON GENERAL FUND ADJUSTMENTS
TO. THERE ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
NINE DOLLARS SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION FUND FOR
JUDICIAL COUNCILS PLAN WILLOW'S
COURTHOUSE RENOVATION AND
ADDITION PROJECT- AND FINALLY
AN APPROPRIATION- TECHNICAL
APPROPRIATIONS BUT EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. IN FEDERAL
FUNDED JUSTIN'S FOR VARIOUS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
PROGRAM. SO WITH ME IN THE ROOM
I HAVE OTHER COLLEAGUES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WOULD ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND- CAN
SPEAK INTO MORE DETAIL OF ANY
OF THE ISSUES. THAT ARE BEING
COVERED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER REMOTE
FROM AT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
A QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THIS BILL INCLUDES
AN APPROPRIATION FOR A LITTLE
OVER TWO POINT FOUR MILLION-DOLLARS TO THE PART OF JUSTICE
TO PAY CLAIMS RELATED TO A
COURT CASE WHICH IS BERMAN
VERSUS CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY.
THAT APPROPRIATION IS BEING
MADE. GOOD AFTERNOON. ERIN
EDWARDS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THAT
APPROPRIATION- THE STATE WAS.
SUED AND- TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
ALONG WITH THE- SAN FRANCISCO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. OR BASED
ON A CHALLENGE TO PENAL CODE
SECTION SIXTEEN TWENTY NINE
BEING- WHICH REQUIRES COUNTIES
TO PREPARE AND IMPLEMENT BILL
SCHEDULES THE STATE WAS
DISMISSED OUT OF THE CASE-
WITHIN THE YEAR ELEVENTH
AMENDMENT. IMMUNITY GROUNDS IT
DID NOT WITH TO GET THE CASE
DURING THE ENSUING YEARS.
HOWEVER ALTHOUGH THE STATE WAS
DISMISSED OUT OF THE CASE THE
DISTRICT COURT ORDERED THE
STATE TO PAY FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CASE. AND THE AG'S
OFFICE HAS APPEALED THIS ORDER
TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT WILL BE
BRIEFING WITHIN THE COMING
MONTHS- IN THE MEANTIME. THE
STATE HAS BEEN ORDERED TO POST
BOND. OF ONE POINT TWO FIVE
TIMES- THE FEET ORDER OF ONE
POINT NINE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. BY OCTOBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THIS IS EQUATES
TO THE TWO POINT THREE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS- IN THE BUDGET
ACT AMENDMENT THE AG'S OFFICE
IS SEEKING DISMISSAL OF THE
ORDER. I'M WILL HOPEFULLY GET A
DECISION IN THE COMING MONTHS-
BUT THE SUCCESS OF THAT MOTION
IS UNCERTAIN AT THIS TIME SO-
WE ARE SEEKING THIS
APPROPRIATION- IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET- JUST IN CASE D.
AG IS UNSUCCESSFUL AND THAT
PETITION AND THE I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR ALSO. INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE SPECIFYING
THAT THESE FUNDS- IT CAN ONLY
BE USEDUPON APPROVAL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
NOTIFICATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
SO POSTING A BOND. WOULD NOT
REQUIRE US TO APPROPRIATE MONEY
THAT'S JUST TO GUARANTEE OF
PAYMENT IT JUST I'M CONCERNED
THAT IT MIGHT BE PREMATURE TO
APPROPRIATE THAT MONEY. GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE- AWARD IS- IS
UNDER APPEAL AND ALSO FRANKLY
IN THE LARGER SENSE GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THIS IS A MATTER
THAT'S GOING BEFORE THE VOTERS
IN THE FORM OF AN INITIATIVE ON
THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER. IT'S
CERTAINLY CAN APPRECIATE THE
THAT SENTIMENT- I THINK OUR
VIEW IS THAT IT'S- IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THE APPROPRIATIONS SET
ASIDE. I GIVEN THAT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THAT
CASEWILL BE- IT IS- I THINK.
IN OUR VIEW- APPROPRIATE-
BUDGETING- JUST TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THAT APPROPRIATIONS
ALREADY. OUR. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE JUST FOR THE PUBLIC
FOR INFORMATION WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH ALL SIX BILLS AND THEN
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL OF
THEM. TOGETHER SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO SB EIGHT ONE FIVE THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT AUGUST CLEAN
UP. FOR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'LL HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THE PROVISIONS IN SB EIGHT ONE
FIVE. SB ONE ONE FIVE WOULD
ENACT THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
IMPROVEMENT CATS TAX VOUCHER
ACT WHICH TASKS THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE TREASURY AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO DEVELOP A TAX
VOUCHER PROGRAM AND PRESENT
THAT PROGRAM PROPOSAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE. NO LATER THAN
MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE ACT MAKES CERTAIN ASPECTS
OCCASIONS REGARDING THE PROGRAM
INCLUDING THAT THESE TAX
FACTORS UP COULD BE CREDIT GET
COULD BE CREDITED AGAINST A
TAXPAYERS FUTURE TAX LIABILITY.
BOTH PERSONAL INCOME AS WELL AS
A CORPORATE INCOME. TAX ALSO
EXCUSE ME THAT THE TAX VOUCHER
ACT ALSO SPECIFIES THAT THE
COLLECTIONS COULD BE USED FOR A
VARIETY OF PURPOSES. INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO ECONOMIC
STIMULUS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HOMELESS REDUCTION WAS NICE
REDUCTION EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ECONOMIC MITIGATION PROGRAMS
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND GREEN
ECONOMY INVESTMENTS. SB EIGHT
ONE FOR WOULD ALSO REMAIN
RESTRUCTURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS. SPECIFICALLY DEBBIE-
WOULD BE RENAMED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. THE
BILL RESTRUCTURES THE
DEPARTMENT IN WAYS THAT WOULD
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN ITS TWO
LICENSING DIVISIONS THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND THE DIVISION
OF CORPORATIONS. IN ADDITION
THE LINK IN THE LANGUAGE MERGES
THE TWO MAIN FUNDS THAT SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT INTO A SINGLE
FUND. IMPORTANTLY THE LANGUAGE
DOES NOT IMPLEMENTED THE
PROPOSED CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION LAW. I
LASTLY I'LL JUST NOTE THAT- SB
EIGHT ONE FIVE ALSO WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPOSIT THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO MAKE
CERTAIN T- DATA AVAILABLE
REGARDING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS BEGINNING
SEPTEMBER FOURTH AND WOULD
REQUIRE THAT DATA TO BE UPDATED
EVERY TWO WEEKS THROUGH JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS
DATA WOULD INCLUDE THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS PAID SINCE MARCH THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMS FOUND IN
ELIGIBLE SINCE MARCH THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE NEVER
CERTIFIED FOR BENEFITS AND THE
NUMBER OF PAYMENTS WERE NOT
PROVIDED WAGE INFORMATION TO
QUALIFY FOR CLAIMS. THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS ARE PENDING
DEPARTMENT RESOLUTION AND THE
NUMBER OF CALLS AND UNIQUE
COLORS- THAT- STAFF OF ANSWERED
AND IN THAT TWO WEEK PERIOD THE
LANGUAGE ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
ANY CHANGES OR AMENDMENTS TO
THIS DATA I WOULD MAKE WOULD
NEED TO BE SUBMITTED IN WRITING
TO THE CHAIR OF THE JAIL BC.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC FINANCE NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS COOK WHAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE L.
A. O. DID A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE MORE
NOTABLE- CHANGES IN SB A
FIFTEEN THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL- SO- WITH THAT I
WOULD JUST TURN IT OVER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE BY WE I HAVE.
JOINED HERE- WITH COLLEAGUES
FROM THE PART OF THE FINANCE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE HOUSE. THANK YOU JUST
GOT TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
MISTER WHAT. QUESTION FOR THE
L. A. L. I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROVISION IN THIS
TRAILER BILL. THAT EXTENDS THE
PERIOD BY WHICH ASSESSMENT
APPEAL BOARDS. ARE REQUIRED TO
RULE ON TAXPAYER APPEALS OF
THEIR PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS.
BY UP TO A YEAR I'M WONDERING
WHY THAT PROVISION WAS INCLUDED.
I'M SORRY WEWOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THE INTENT BEHIND
THE INCLUSION OF THE PERSON.
OKAY PERHAPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEM. YES
CRISCO FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL. ACTUALLY WILL I SHOULD
BACK UP SO THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO EXTEND
THE DEADLINE FOR- CHINESE TO
HEAR PROPERTY TAX APPEALS. THAT
DATE WAS EXTENDED THROUGH
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THIS
TRAILER BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY
EXTENDED THROUGH MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWO MONTHS. OKAY I
KNOW WHAT IT IS BECAUSE I READ
THE BILL. I'M ONE OKAY WHY WHY
THAT YOU FEEL THE CHANGES
NECESSARY. RIGHT SO. THANK YOU
SO- THE CHANGES NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE- BECAUSE OF COLD
WEATHER THERE'S BEEN SOME-
HARDSHIPS ON COUNTIES AND BEING
ABLE TO HEAR THESE ARE THESE
HEARINGS IN ADEQUATE TIME. AND
SO A LOT OF THE HEARINGS THEY
WERE UP WITH THE THEY'RE UP
AGAINST THEIR TO YOUR CLOCK.
THAT CLOCK ENDED IN JULY AND
SO- BECAUSE OF THEIR INABILITY
TO CONDUCT THE HEARINGS IN A
TIMELY MATTER IN HERE THESE
APPEALS- FROM- INDIVIDUAL
PROPERTY OWNERS ON THE PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENTS- THE EXTENSION
WAS PROVIDED TO THEM THAT THE
COUNTIES TO ALLOW THEM TO- FIND
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OR TO GET
THROUGH THOSE ARE- THOSE.
APPEALS ALL RIGHT- I JUST HAVE
A SERIOUS CONCERN THAT. YOU
KNOW IN MOST CASES WHEN WE
EXTEND THE STATUTORY DEADLINES
WE'RE GIVING FLEXIBILITY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ELECTED US IN THE
TAXPAYERS WHO PAY OUR SALARIES.
I IN THIS CASE WE'RE DOING THE
OPPOSITE WHERE WE'RE GRANTING
GOVERNMENT ADDITIONAL POWER AND
AUTHORITY- TO- AND TIME TO RULE
ON THESE THESE MATTERS WHICH I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT MOST OF
THESE ASSESSMENT APPEALS
BOARDS- COULD TRIAGE THEM AND
TAKE THE ONES THAT THEY THOUGHT
THAT THEY WEE MOST LIKELY TO
PREVAIL ON OR THEY'RE-
REPRESENTED THE GREATEST AMOUNT
OF- OF DISPUTE OVER TAXPAYER
DOLLARS YOU KNOW IN N HERE
THOSE NOW. WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY DO HAVE AND SELF I
REALLY OBJECT TO HAVING THAT
INCLUDED BECAUSE I THINK- YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S KIND OF A-
RATHER THAN BEING FLEXIBLE WITH
WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS IT'S
DOING THE OPPOSITE SO- THAT-
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS FOR THE
ANSWER. THANK YOUNG I WOULD SAY
AS A FORMER COUNTY ASSESSOR-
YOU KNOW I WAS THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR DURING THE LAST GREAT
RECESSION. IN JUST TO SET.
MATTER OF CONTEXT FOR THE
PUBLIC ON THE AMOUNT OF APPEALS
THAT WE GOT- DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION TO THE PREVIOUS
RECESSION WHICH IS AROUND TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND TWO.
WAS SEVEN AX SO JUST TO GIVE
PEOPLE A SENSE ON. THE PEAK IN
APPEALS WAS ABOUT- I THOUSAND
APPEALS ROUGHLY- PER YEAR IN
THAT PERIOD- WHICH IS MUCH
HIGHER THAN THE NORMAL. IN
AGAIN ON MANY OF THE PEELS THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH THESE PORTS
AT LEAST IN MY COUNTY MY COMES
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT ARE
MOSTLY. THAT COMPLEX PROPERTY
SAYS NOT THE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES IT'S- IT WAS THE EIGHTEEN
T. BALLPARK IT'S THE BANK OF
AMERICA BUILDING AT THE
TRANSAMERICA BUILDING IT'S THE
FERRY BUILDING SO ALL VERY VERY
COMPLEX. A TOUCH CASES WE WENT
UP TO ABOUT- FROM ONE THOUSAND
CASES TO ALMOST LIKE SEVEN
THOUSAND CASES A YEAR. AND SO
THAT TYPE OF- WORKLOAD WE JUST-
THERE'S NOT NONE OF THE
COUNTIES WERE PREPARED AND
GIVEN THAT THIS RECESSION
POTENTIALLY IS WORSE. THAN EVEN
THAT- GREAT RECESSION- THERE
THERE'S A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES- I BELIEVE
THERE ARE COUNTIES HOPEFULLY
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT- LATER
THAN THIS LATER IN THE SEGMENT
TO. REALLY GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF- BOTH THE PROS
AND CONS OF THIS PROPOSAL SO WE
EAGERLY AWAIT THAT BUT- A LOT
OF IT IS JUST THE HUGE AMOUNT
OF WORKLOAD THAT COMES. IN FOR
MOST COUNTIES. MOST MOST COUNT
KALRA AUTOMATIC. RE ASSESS DOWN
SING FAMILY HOMES. BECAUSE IT'S
A FOR THESE PROCEDURES IS A
SIGNIFICANT OUT OF DATA- IT'S
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING TO DO
THAT- FOR MORE CONTACT
PROPERTIES AS OPPOSED TO HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A LONGER TERM.
APPEALS PROCESS BUT THAT THAT'S
ALSO WHY WE NEED TO HAVE THE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR. OTHER
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SING
AND WE ARE GOING TO GO TO SB
EIGHT TWO OF OUR EDUCATION
CLEAN UP. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
JOHN MEMBERS ARE GOOD QUALITY
WITH FEDERAL OFFICE. SB EIGHT
TWENTY OF THE EDUCATIONAL MEDIA
TRAILER BILL THERE ARE CHANGES
RELATED TO CAN'T FALL. CHILD
<c.green>ARE AND HIGHER EDUCATION. I</c>
WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT THREE OF
THE- MORE NOTABLE CHANGES.
FIRST WAS RELATED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT GROWTH. SO BUT THE DESIGN.
THIS BILL PROVIDE. ACROSS FOR.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES TO BE
ABLE TO- RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING BASED ON OUR GROWTH IN
ATTENDANCE. AS YOU MAY RECALL
THAT YOU MAY NOT THE BUDGET-
STEPPED UP FUNDING LEVEL BASED
ON ATTENDANCE FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. THE LIST OF
THESE PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW BUT
SCHOOL DISTRICT TORRANCE COURT
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. TO
APPLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
GROWTH FUNDING. AND THE
PERSONAL GROWTH FUNDING WOULD
BE PROVIDED. IF THE IF THEY
WOULD DEMONSTRATE THAT CAN
DEMONSTRATE OUR TWO THINGS
FIRST THAT. THERE WAS A
PROJECTED ENROLLMENT GROWTH-
YEAH YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT COULD
YOU BUDGET OR IN OUR- PREVIOUS
IN OUR ESTIMATES IN THE SPRING.
CHIU AND THEN THE SECOND THING
IS THAT THE DEMONSTRATE THAT
THERE WOULD BE- ACTUAL
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. A GROWTH
BASED ON. A FALSE SENSE AT THE
MOMENT. I'M THE AND A MAJOR I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT A AN
APPROPRIATE OF EIGHTY DOLLAR IN
NINETY FUND. RELATED TO CHINA.
THIS IS A ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR ENHANCED. REIMBURSEMENT
RATE FOR MEALS WERE PROVIDED
BETWEEN- MARCH AND AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY- BUT BUT YOU'RE
NOT THE BUDGET ALREADY INCLUDED
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS PER MEAL. I
WAS PROVIDED DURING THIS
PERIOD. THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
JUST- PROVIDE GREATER
ASSURANCES THAT THE STATE WOULD
BE ABLE TO FIND OUT SEVENTY
FIVE CENTS PER. ORDINARY AND
THEN FINALLY RID CHILD KERR
THERE IS A- CHANGE TO FAMILY
FEES. SO YOU MAY RECALL THAT
THERE ARE SOME SMALL- SLIDING
SCALE FEES. FOR OUR FAMILIES
THAT RECEIVE SUBSIDIES
CHAPARRAL PRESCHOOL- BUT THE
BILL SB EIGHT TWENTY- WEAVE
THOSE FEES RETROACTIVELY FOR
JULY AND AUGUST. AND PROVIDE
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS-
REPORTER FOR THAT PURPOSE- THE-
THEN FROM SEPTEMBER THROUGH
JUNE- FEES WOULD BE WAIVED FOR
ANY FAMILIES WHO WERE- WELL I'M
NOT ABLE TO OR NOT
PARTICIPATING OR NOT BE ABLE TO
SEND THEIR CHILD ON FLIGHT SO.
IN SOME CASES- CONTRACT
PROVIDED TO THE STATE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE SOME DISTANCE
LEARNING OPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE
FOR PRESCHOOL STUDENTS. BOTH
FAMILIES WOULD NOT BE REQUIRED
TO BE USED- TO THE EXTENT-
THAT- THERE ARE NOT FEES ARE
NOT COLLECTED DURING THAT
PERIOD PROVIDERS- WOULD BE THE
ONES THAT WOULD ABSORB THE
COST. I'M UNLESS THERE'S
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING FROM
THE INACTIVE BUDGET HAVE A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS THAT
SPECIFY IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR TALKS AT.
AN EARLY LEARNING HOW THOSE
FUNDS SHOULD BE SPENT. SB EIGHT
TWENTY- STARTS COVERING BECAUSE
APPARENTLY HE'S ABOUT FIRST
PRIORITY WITH ADDITIONAL
PERFORMANCE- THOSE ARE THE
THREE MAJOR ON. THE HIGH LIFE
AND IT ON CERTAIN QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THANK YOU GOOD FINANCE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
THIS IS JUST HOMES DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- MR CABRAL DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN I'M GIVING AN
OVERVIEW OF THE SB TWENTY I
WOULD JUST ADD A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL PIECES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL THE BILL
DOES- CLARIFY ALLOWABLE USES
AND EXTEND THE EXPENDITURE
PERIOD FOR SOME OF THE FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION IN LEARNING
LOSS MITIGATION FUNDS. THAT
WERE APPROPRIATED IN SB EIGHTY
NINE- IN ADDITION THE BILL
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF PAID
OFF NON OPERATIONAL DAYS FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THAT
ACCEPT STATE VOUCHERS- AND
FINALLY THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
GREATER DETAIL ON THE MISSION
AND COMPOSITION OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE'S TASK FORCE. I'M I'M
ALSO HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
CHRIS. HIGHER EDUCATION. SURE
HERTZBERG SOME OF THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SB ONE
TWENTY OR SB EIGHT TWENTY ON
THE HIGHER EDUCATION FRONT ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONS TO ADD THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EXTENDS THE DEADLINE
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT A POLICY
IMPLEMENTING THE NATIVE
AMERICAN GRAVES PROTECTION ACT
OUR PROTECTION AND REPATRIATION
ACT THAT IS- IT ALLOWS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
UTILIZE THE SAVINGS FROM
CERTAIN- BOND REFINANCINGS. FOR
A BOWL OR FOR THREE THINGS- AT
THAT WOULD BE A IT'S UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITY- POTENTIALLY
AVOIDING ANY LAYOFFS THAT COULD
OTHERWISE. OCCUR AND TO SUPPORT
OUR UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS-
AND THEN LASTLY- THE BILL WOULD
PROVIDE FOR THE STATE LIBRARY
TO BE ABLE TO. RECEIVE CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY RATHER
THAN IN PHYSICAL PRINT FORM.
THANK YOU I ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MR
FONG. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THAT'S A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
HERE FOR VARIOUS REASONS BUT
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS THIS
PANDEMIC A LOT OF. PARENTS ARE
CHOOSING TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO.
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS
WHY IN THIS- TRAILER BILL ARE.
THE FUND IS THE FUNDING
PROHIBITED TO GO TO STUDENTS
THAT ATTEND NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS. YES THIS IS
JESSICA HOLMES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
THOUGHT BEHIND- THE NON
INCLUSION OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS AND EIGHTY A
GROWTH WAS TO ALIGN WITH THE
POLICY DECISION THAT WAS MADE
IN EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH FIVE- THAT
WAS. JUST RECENTLY PASSED WHICH
PUT A MORATORIUM ON GROWTH FOR
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SO
THIS IS AN ALIGNMENT- WITHIN
THAT POLICY AGREEMENTS. BUT AS
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZE
THAT NOW DURING THE PANDEMIC
THAT THERE IS GROWTH OR THERE
IS INCREASED DEMAND NOW FOR NON
BUT QUESTION BAY STARTERS DON'T
WE SHOULDN'T WE ADJUST FOR THE
REALITY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. WE CERTAINLY I
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME FAMILIES
MAY- MAY BE WISHING TO UTILIZE
A DIFFERENT- ALLEVIATE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY I'M OTHER
THAN WHAT THEY WERE CURRENTLY
IN DURING THE PANDEMIC- THAT IS
TRUE BOTH ON THE NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SIDE THE CLASS-
SIDE. AND THE LOCAL AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SIDE- DEPENDING
UPON YOU KNOW WHAT- WHAT
SERVICES THEY'RE LOOKING FOR OR
IF IT WAS TO MOVE- DUE TO COOK
AT NINETEEN OR THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING- RECOGNIZING ALL
OF THESE THINGS AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WE ARE PREVENT.
REQUIRING LGAS TO TAKE ON-
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS AND
DEFERRALS AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE PROVIDE A HOLD HARMLESS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR.
AS WELL AS FUNDING
EXTRAORDINARY POTENTIALLY
EXTRAORDINARY GROWTH- OR
MOVEMENTS I SHOULD SAY BETWEEN
ELEAZAR- DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR IT'S
VERY LIKELY THAT WOULD HAVE TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF DEFERRALS THAT WE
HAVE- IN THE CURRENT YEAR SOWE
BELIEVE THAT THAT. THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN E. S. B. TWENTY- IS A
GOOD COMPROMISE- IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING- SOME EIGHTY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR EIGHTY A GROWTH
THAT WAS PLANNED- BUT NOT
NECESSARILY EXPOSING THE STATE
TO THE FISCAL LIABILITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE POTENTIAL-
SIGNIFICANT MOVEMENT. AMONG
ELEAZAR DURING THE NINETEEN.
SUGGESTS THAT TO BE CLEAR THEN
THE ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT THERE IS SOME TYPE OF AN
INEQUITY WHEN IT COMES TO.
FUNDING NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
VERT WHEN YOU COMPARE NON
CUSTOM PAID CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
THE REST OF. THE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. I DON'T KNOW
THAT I WOULD CHARACTERIZE IT
THAT WAY I WOULD SAY THAT-
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE ALSO BEEN
ELIGIBLE TO DRIVE DOWN. I'M
FUNDING SOURCES SUCH AS A
FEDERAL PAYMENT PROTECTION
PROGRAM FUNDS- THAT OTHER LEDS
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
SO- THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT-
THERE MANY DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES THAT DIFFERENT ELITES
CAN ACCESS AND- YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT A SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE OR CHARTER SCHOOL
IS BETTER OFF. UNDER ONE
CIRCUMSTANCE IN THE OTHER IT'S
REALLY GONNA BE DEPENDING UPON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
INDIVIDUAL L. YAY. I APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR ANSWER YOUR CANDOR I
JUST RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS ROOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- THERE'S
A PROVISION- AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN YOUR-
I REMARKS BUT IN THE WRITTEN
MATERIALS THAT REQUIRES THE-
THE UC TO CERTIFY. TO THE DLF
ANNUALLY THAT THE BUILDINGS
BUILT THROUGH STATE FUNDED
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROCESS ARE
BEING OPERATED AND MAINTAINED
BY YOU SEE EMPLOYEES- IS THAT A
PROVISION RELATING TO-
ESSENTIALLY CERTIFYING THAT
THERE'S NO CONTRACTING OUT. AND
IF SO CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN THE
THINKING BEHIND THAT. SO
CERTAINLY- I GUESS I CAN-
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL CONTEXT
THIS IS A NO A LEGISLATIVE UP
LANGUAGE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL THAT THAT IS IN THE
YOU HAVE TRAILER BILL- THE
INTENT OF THAT LANGUAGE IS TO.
ESTABLISH WHAT THEY CALL IN
FORCING WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH- THE RECENTLY ADOPTED AND
SIGNED COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT- WITH SOME OF ITS
SITE WITH YOU SEE AND IT
SERVICE WORKERS- WHAT I CAN SAY
IS THAT. UP FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES PER WE'RE NOT A
POSITION TO SOME THAT LINE
TODAY BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT
IS IN THE TRAILER BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THAT THAT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS RIGHT NOW IT'S
A TWO PARTY AGREEMENT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE.
WAS SOME TUSSLING BACK AND
FORTH OVER OVER THIS PROVISION
IT DOES STRIKE ME AS- BEING A
LITTLE BIT UNUSUAL THAT.
SOMETHING THAT IS THE SUBJECT
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT IS NOW BEING. ADDING
A REQUIREMENT IN TRAILER BILL I.
FOR CERTIFICATION I'M NOT SURE
WHY THAT WOULDN'T. JUST BE
COVERED BY THE COLLECTIVE
AGREEMENT AND NOT NEED TO OUR
INTERVENTION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
IT'S AWFUL BY. THEY'LL STAND TO
LOSE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FUNDING THE
CONDUCTOR LOTTERIES IN REAL
STUDENTS FOR NEXT YEAR I MEAN
HARD HIRING DECISIONS
ACCORDINGLY THE ONLY TWO
OPTIONS THEY HAVE EITHER
DESYREL STUDENTS AS ALLOWABLE
UNDER PROPOSAL FOR EDUCATE
NEWSROOMS WITHOUT FUNDING. JUST
HAS JUST DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
STILL SO WHY NOT IMPOSE A CAP
ON HOW MUCH NOT CLASSROOM BASED
GOALS CAN BE FUNDED RESIDENT
OUT RIGHT EXCLUSION OF GROW
FUNDING FOR THE SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M FOR THE
QUESTION SO AGAIN- THIS
LANGUAGE IS INTENDED TO BE IN
ALIGNMENT- WITH AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE WHICH AGAIN- IMPOSED A
MORATORIUM ON A CLUSTER BASED
CHARTERS- FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR. BUT BUT
FIFTEEN OH FIVE WAS FOR NEW NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER'S NOT
ENROLLMENT AND GROWTH EXISTING
SCHOOLS CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT. THANK YOU. IN THIS
REGARD. THANK YOU YOU KNOW.
I'LL TALK ABOUT THE UC THING
BUT THIS THIS THIS FIRST ISSUE
AS FAR AS THE- NON CLASSROOM
BASED GROWTH AND THIS WAS A BIG
ISSUE IN THE JUNE BUDGET AND I
THINK JUST JUST I THINK IT'S
AND MISS. EGGMAN DISTRICT
MISTER COOPER NOT YOURS BUT
JUST MAYBE SOUTH OF YOURS IS. A
COMMUNITY THAT'S GOT A BIG
DEVELOPMENT FROM BURY PEOPLE
COMING OVER AND- THEY'RE
ESSENTIALLY THEY'RE POPULATION
OR SCHOOL DISTRICT IS GOING
FROM LIKE THREE THOUSAND TO
SOME LIKE SIX THOUSAND MEALS
NUMBERS ARE CORRECT. IN THE
NEXT YEAR AND WHEN 95% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASKED US YOU
KNOW COBIT NINETEEN IS
HAPPENING THE SKY IS FALLING.
JUST HOLD HARMLESS CAPPER EDA
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE TODAY
INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
SAME ISSUE PEOPLE ARE COMING TO
SCHOOL THEY'RE STAYING HOME
SOMEONE A CAP. EIGHTY EIGHT SO
WE MADE THE TOUGH CHOICES FARMS
OKAY WE'RE GONNA CAP WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA FREEZE IT
FREEZE YOUR FUNDING IT TO DRAW
A LINE IN THE SAND SO YOU HAVE
TO DRAW THE LINE SOMEWHERE. IT
WASN'T TO HAVE SOME PLOY TO
HARM THESE OTHER ENTITIES
THAT'S WHERE WE WORK WHERE WE
WORK LAST MARCH APRIL AND MAY.
WE ADOPTED THE BUDGET IN JUNE.
AND WE KNOW THAT ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS ARE FRANKLY DISTANCE
LEARNING INCLUDING THESE THESE
THESE CHARTERS BUT- 95% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WHAT ARE AND
ARE IN DEEP DEEP TROUBLE AND-
WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND I THINK
WE FIX THE BIGGEST ISSUE HERE
WITH THIS WITH THIS PLAN
GROWTH- AND SO I THINK THAT
IT'S A FAIR COMPROMISE. IT
HOLDS- THAT THE DISTRICTS-
HARMLESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT ARE IN GREAT FINANCIAL
PERIL. AS NOTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SOME OF
THESE- ENTITIES THAT ARE ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS. THERE IS
A LOT OF FEDERAL FUNDS TO THEY
RECEIVE THESE MAJOR PPO AWARDS
THAT. SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE
AVAILABLE TO GET TO SO THAT'S-
NOT INTO CONSIDERATION HERE SO
I DON'T THINK IT'S- NECESSARILY
A PUNITIVE. PEACE GOING AFTER
ONE BECAUSE IT'S REALLY FOCUSED
ON- YOU KNOW THAT THE LARGER.
PICTURE AS FAR AS HOLDING OUR
OUR SCHOOLS. AND IN A VIABLE
PLACE TO GET THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- WITH THAT I THINK
THAT IT WAS A FAIR COMPROMISE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OUTLINED IT. AS WELL- I JUST I
DO WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE UC
THING- I UNDERSTAND THAT. IT'S
NOT A THREE PARTY AGREEMENT AND
SO CERTAINLY THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS THE RIGHT TO BLUE PENCIL
THIS AT THE END- BUT IT I GUESS
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS. IS
THIS JUST A- FURTHERANCE OF OUR
OF OUR PRIOR ACTIONS AS FAR AS-
CONTRACTING OUT THE NEAREST TO
CALIFORNIA OR JUST A NEW. IS
THERE ISTHIS A NEW- KIND OF
OBLIGATION ON TOP OF THAT. OKAY
SO THE PROCESS THE WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED- IN THE TRAILER
BILL IT'S ABOVE AND BEYOND-
WHAT IS CURRENT LAW AND THE
CURRENT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT- BETWEEN- YOU SEE AND
THEIR PARTNERS. YEAH. GOTCHA SO
THIS PROBABLY QUIT WENT TO WHAT
WAS IN HAD IT BEEN- HAD BEEN
SUCCESSFUL LEGISLATURE PUT ON
THE BALLOT WAS THE CA FOURTEEN
THAT RIGHT. I THINK THEY'RE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT- THE
LANGUAGE CERTAINLY AN ACA
FOURTEEN VERSES THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN SB EIGHT TWENTY ARE
VERY DIFFERENT. OKAY. AND THEN
LASTLY I'M SORRY I DID HAVE A
NOTE HERE WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE K. TWELVE CAN YOU CAN YOU
ANSWER THE QUESTION BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE I KNOW WE HAD
THIS FIFTEEN OF FIVE AND THE
BOOK OF THE LAW ON THE GROWTH
FROM NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS BUT IF THERE ARE
EXISTING- NON CLASSROOM BASED
TRADERS AND THERE AND THERE HAD
BEEN PLANNED GROWTH THAT
PLANNED GROWTH. IS FUNDED IT'S
JUST THE GROWTH THAT'S NOT IN
RESPONSE TO COVET GROWTH
POTENTIALLY THAT ACCURATE THE
LANGUAGE IN SB EIGHT TWENTY-
DOES NOT ALLOW NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS TO RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR- ANY TYPE OF
GROWTH- ABOVE THE NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT LEVEL.
CORRECT WE ARE ALLOWING FOR
PLANNED GROWTH FOR. CHARTERS
FIRST CLASS FOR CLASS CLASSROOM
BASED TRAINING LASTING BASIS
PLANNED GROWTH. YES CORRECT
OKAY WANNA CLARIFY THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MMHM. MISTER
MONTE. I ALSO HAD A QUESTION ON
THAT THE- CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER ISSUE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO. AS WE
ALL KNOW THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS HAS BEEN IN
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT. WHAT FORM.
ADDITIONAL AID TO STATES IS
GOING TO TAKE AS A RESULT OF
THE CROSSFIRE CHRIS CRISIS AND
THEIR BILLS PENDING IN BOTH
CHAMBERS BUT THE BILL THAT'S
PENDING IN THE SENATE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES STATES
NOT TO PENALIZE CHARTER SCHOOLS
IN RESPECT TO TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS. AT THE RISK OF LOSING
THAT FEDERAL AID SO DO DO YOU
WORRY THAT SHOULD THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL PASSED THEN-
CALIFORNIA WILL YOU WILL LOSE
THAT FUNDING IF THAT BILL
BECOMES LAW. THANK YOU I CAN'T
REALLY COMMENT ON- PENDING
LEGISLATION HOWEVER- I WOULD
NOTE THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING-
WHAT. IS HAPPENING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL VERY CLOSELY- FOR
NUMBER OBVIOUSLY OF REASONS-
AND AT THIS POINT WE FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE IN THE POSITION
THAT RAT. WELL I DON'T. AND I
THINK A NUMBER OF US DON'T. AND
THE REASON IS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LONG TRADITION IN THE STATE OF.
ALLOWING FUNDING TO FOLLOW THE
STUDENT. AND WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
ARE CHOOSING NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS TO WHETHER THIS
CRISIS- I FULLY SUPPORT THE
DECISION. TO COMPENSATE OUR
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FOR LOSS OF ENROLLMENT THAT'S-
THAT'S- OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF
THE- THE EPIDEMIC I THINK THAT
MAKES PERFECT SENSE AND WE DID
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE READY WILLING AND
ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE STUDENTS
WHEN THEY COME BACK INTO
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS- SETTINGS
BUT- BUT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE TO ME. TO REFUSE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR- THE
SETTINGS THAT THESE PARENTS ARE
CHOOSING TO SEND THEIR THEIR
STUDENTS INTO SO I RE I'M
REALLY HOPING THAT. SURE THIS
MOVE FOR THAT- WE RECONSIDER
THAT PORTION OF IT AND- NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH IS BECAUSE I
THINK IT PUTS A SERIOUSLY IN
DANGER. OF LOSING OUT ON THOSE
FEDERALLY DOLLARS. I'M JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE UC ISSUE I'M
IN A KIND OF STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS. WHY
THIS IS SOMETHING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT A
QUESTION FOR THE L. A. JUST TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND. SO IF
WE IF WE HAVE TO GIVE YOU A
REAL WORLD EXAMPLE FROM MY
LOCAL YOU SEE. IF WE'VE GOT
SOME BUILDINGS. WITH ELEVATORS
AND THEM. AND THOSE ELEVATORS
NEED TO BE PERIODICALLY
MAINTAINED DOES THAT MEAN THAT.
THE SCHOOL HAS TO EMPLOY. A FOR
A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE JUST TO DO
A LOT FOR ELEVATOR MAINTENANCE.
THE END AND THEY GET THEY'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO CONTRACT OUT
THAT- THAT LABOR. EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S ENOUGH FULL TIME WORK
FOR- FOR AN ELEVATOR
MAINTENANCE REPAIRMAN IS THAT
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT RIGHT.
THIS IS JENNIFER. WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
AND WE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
ANALYZE THE BILL BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF IT IS- I CAN
SEE WHAT YOU SUGGEST. SO JUST
FOR AT WE THINK WHAT THIS
PROVISION YOU DOES IS PROHIBIT
SEE CONTRACTING OUT FOR CERTAIN
SUPPORT SERVICES THEY MIGHT NOT
NEED TO HIRE AT A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE TO DO THAT JOB BUT
THEY WOULD NEED TO BE A UC
EMPLOYEE. TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE AS FINANCE MENTIONED
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM A CA
FOURTEEN WHICH SAID THAT YOU
SEE IF IT CONTRACTS OUT MUST
TREAT THAT CONTRACTED OUT
EMPLOYEE THE SAME AS THEY WOULD
A YOU SEE EMPLOYEE. SO WE DO
KNOW FROM SOME VERY PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION THAT WE GOT THAT
ARE YOU SEEN EMPLOYEE ON
AVERAGE JUST MAKE MORE THAN ONE
ENTERED PLAY WHICH TYPICALLY BE
PAID FULL SALARY AND WAIT
BENEFITS. FOR YOU SEE
CONTRACTING OUT. FOR THAT
PARTICULAR SERVICE. AND THESE
ARE TWO DECISION BEFORE YOU
WHETHER YOU WANT TO DO THIS IS
PART OF YOUR BUT PROCESS. AS
PART OF FOR. IS PART OF A
COLLECTIVE. PROCESS THOSE
OBVIOUSLY ARE KEY DECISIONS
BEFORE YOU RIGHT WELL I MEAN
THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M STRUGGLING
WITH IS WHY. IN THE MIDST OF A
RECESSION IN A PANDEMIC WE
WOULD CHOOSE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT IS INCREASING COSTS FOR.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE UC IS I MEAN WE ALL
KNOW. THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
PROVIDE THE BEST. EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THEY CAN FOR THE
DOLLARS THAT WE GIVE THEM AND
IF THEY CONTRACT OUT MADE IT'S
ONLY BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
BE COST EFFICIENT WITH THEIR
DOLLARS. YEAH AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT WELL MY LOCAL YOU SEE
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVES THAT THAT'S
WORK CORPORATE PART OF THE LAW
REQUIRES THEM TO DO IN FACT.
THERE'S A CURRENT POLICY THAT
REQUIRES THIS IS NOT STATURE
IT- AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
FORCED TO DO IS TO HIRE SOMEONE
FULL TIME WITH A SPECIALIZED
TRAINING TO DO ELEVATOR
MAINTENANCE EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T HAVE FULL TIME WORK. FOR
AN ELEVATOR MAINTENANCE REPAIR
REPAIRMAN AND- THAT THAT'S
RIDICULOUS SO- I WOULD I WOULD
URGE THIS COMMITTEE. TO
RECONSIDER THAT PARTICULAR
PROVISION OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. YES THANK YOU I TO WHAT I
WANT TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
TO THOSE OF YOU. IT SAYS HERE
IN OUR BUDGET THAT WE HAVE SET
A MINIMUM- DAYS OF INSTRUCTION
AND A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF-
MINUTES I GUESS FOR
INSTRUCTION. OF DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE I SEE WE HEAR
WHAT WE'RE ALLOWING OF COURSE
IS ABOUT A FOUR DAYS. SCHOOL
WEEK IF THEY CHOOSE- AND- BUT
IT ALSO SAYS THAT WE'VE CREATED
A MINIMUM STANDARD OF
DESTRUCTION OF DAY IN THE
MINUTES REQUIREMENTS WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE MINIMUM. STANDARD
THAT WE'RE PUTTING TO FORCE
RIGHT NOW IN THE IN THE
OBVIOUSLY. OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. YES CERTAINLY DOCTOR
WELL. AND SO THE SB EIGHTY NINE
I'M AT YOURCORRECT IT
MAINTAINS OUR MINIMUM DAILY
MINUTES- AS WELL AS THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS
BUT PROVIDES- SOME FLEXIBILITY
FOR. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ON- TOTAL ANNUAL MINUTES- BE
GOOD AND NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS IS ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS FOR NON
CHARTER LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS-
THE MINIMUM DAILY MINUTES. IS
REALLY DEPENDENT UPON AND THE
GRADE LEVEL OF THE CHILD BUT IT
RANGES FROM ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF HOURS- FOR THE YOUNGEST
CHILDREN- TO MORE THAN. I HAVE.
I THINK IT'S FOUR AND A HALF
HOURS FOR THE OLDER CHILDREN- I
I'LL GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICE ON
THAT BECAUSE THEY CAN BE A
LITTLE BIT OFF ON ON THIS-
HOWEVER AND S. B. AT EIGHT
TWENTY. DOES PROVIDE IT DOES
INCLUDE SOME LANGUAGE THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO SCHOOL. A FEW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO- HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN APPROVED FOR
FOUR DAY SCHOOL WEEKS- AND SO
THE LANGUAGE IN SB TWENTY
THAT'S REGARDING- AT THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AS SPECIFIES
FEWER REQUIRED DAYS- BECAUSE OF
THEIR PREVIOUS AT THAT APPROVAL
FOR A FOUR DAY SCHOOL. SO OKAY
IN ADDITION SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT. THAT THE MINIMUM NUMBER
OF- BASICALLY FOUR AND A HALF
HOURS A DAY IS WHAT WE CONSIDER
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE'RE
GOING FOR FIRST FOR ALL THE-
FOR A FULL SCHOOL DAY IS FOUR
AND A HALF HOURS IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. YEAH IT IT
RANGES DEPENDING ON- THE GREAT
AND AGAIN I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOUR OFFICE ON THAT EXACT
NUMBER FOR LIKE HIGH SCHOOL
IT'S HIGHER FOR HIGH SCHOOL-
BUT IT'S- IT RANGES FROM LIKE I
SAID ABOUT THREE AND A HALF
HOURS FOR- KINDERGARTEN- UP. AS
YOU GO THROUGH THE GREAT AND
WE'RE JESTING THAT YOU SAYING
THAT'S CHANGING. NO THAT'S THAT
IS BEING MAINTAINED IT'S THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF MINUTES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE YEAR.
THAT WE'VE PROVIDED FLEXIBILITY
BUT THAT THE REQUIREMENT ON
MINIMUM DAYS. I'VE BEEN ON DALY
MINUTES IS THE SAME AS IT WAS
CREE COVE IT AS WELL AS THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR NUMBER
OF DAYSIN A YEAR. AND SO THE
ADJUSTMENT WOULD OCCUR BECAUSE
THE SCHOOLS DECIDED TO FOUR
DAYS INSTEAD OF FIVE IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THE LANGUAGE IN
SPM EIGHT TWENTY IS VERY
SPECIFIC TYPE OF I BELIEVE IT'S
THREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AT WHO
HAD. WHO HAD PRIOR TO CO THAT
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED FOR FOUR
DAY SCHOOL WEEKS BECAUSE THEY
ARE AN EXTREMELY RURAL- AND SO
THIS THAT THE BILL JUST
SPECIFIES THAT BECAUSE THEY
WERE NOT. L. ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO HAVE A MINIMUM A NUMBER OF
SCHOOL DAYS THAT SIMILAR TO
OTHER SCHOOLS PARTICLE BUT THAT
THAT CONTINUES DURING CODE.
OKAY AND SO IT DOESN'T AFFECT
THE OTHER SCHOOLDISTRICTS SO
AT ALL NO IT DOES NOT IT DOES
NOT GOOD TO KNOW- I TO- HAVE
CONCERNS OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE SEPARATED OUT. OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BECAUSE I CONSIDER
CHARTER SCHOOLS PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND THEY ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WITH THE FUNDED BY PUBLIC
DOLLARS. SO BUT WE SEPARATED
THEM OUT THE TYPICALLY THOSE
THAT ARE- OF WHO DO A DISTANCE
LEARNING- WHO DON'T HAVE
PHYSICAL CLASSROOMS- A NON
BASED CLASSROOM CHARTER SCHOOLS
WE'VE SEPARATED THEM OUT. AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE
THOSE IN THE STATE BUT IT'S
QUITE A FEW. I KNOW I HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT OR NINE IN MY
DISTRICT- THAT WILL PROBABLY-
YOU KNOW FIND THEMSELVES IN A
POSITION TO BE THE RIDGE- AFTER
HAVING ACCEPTED KIDS. PUTTING
KIDS OUT OR- OR SOMETHING OF
THAT NATURE BECAUSE OF THE LOSS
OF FUNDING. THIS MAY BE THE
FIRST TIME CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
FUNDED ITS CHILDREN IN OTHER
WORDS EVERY JOB THAT COMES IN
THE DOOR GET STATE FUNDING- AND
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. THE
SCHOOLS FUND BUT NOT AT THE
LEVEL OF THE STUDENTS OUT OF
THE YEAR- AND THEN OTHER THIS
OTHER SCHOOLS WHO MADE. MY
EXPERIENCE THE CLASS- ONCE THEY
GET TO SINCE HIS DATE. OF WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE WE WOULD BE
FUNDING SCHOOLS CHILDREN THAT
DON'T EXIST IN THE CLASSROOM
SO. I MEAN THAT THAT I THINK
THAT IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
FOR A CHARTER SCHOOLS TO. TO
TAKE. BECAUSE WE SEPARATED THEM
OUT IN TERMS OF FUNDING. AND
GROWTH WHICH IS THE MOST
UNFORTUNATE FOR THEM- AND MOST
UNFORTUNATE FOR FAMILIES
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE PARENTS AS
THE- HAVE MADE CHOICES. ABOUT
WHERE THEY WANT THE KIDS TO GO
SOMETIMES BASED ON WHAT HAS
HAPPENED THIS PAST YEAR THEY
WANT. AND THEY WANT TO IF
THEY'RE GOING TO DO SOME
DISTANCE LEARNING THAT WE WANT
A DIFFERENT. STRUCTURE FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING OR SOMETHING
OF THAT NATURE SO. IT SEEMS
RATHER- SAY PUNITIVE BUT IT
SEEMS SOMEWHAT PRIMITIVE THAT.
THAT THE SCHOOLS ARE NOT BEING
ADEQUATELY FUNDED- AS WE FUND
EVERYBODY ELSE. M. AND WE
SEPARATED DID NOT CLASSROOM.
BUT WE HAVE A SEPARATED NINE
CLASS. IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SETTING. BECAUSE THEY WILL
PROBABLY A LOTS OF NON
CLASSROOMS OF SCHOOLS. OUT
THERE BE OPENING NEXT WEEK. AND
I THINK THIS AS A RESULT OF
THAT THEY WILL RECEIVE FUNDING-
AT AT AT THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
IN TERMS OF STUDENTS BUT WE'VE
CHOSEN TO. BASICALLY NOT ALLOW
THOSE OTHERS TO BE FUNDED THIS
IS AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION. AS
SOON AS CONVERSATION OCCURRED
IN SOME BUDGET HEARING
SOMEWHERE. OF THAT OF. THAT
OBVIOUSLY I WASN'T PART OF
BECAUSE I'M NOT ON THAT
COMMITTEE BUT NONETHELESS. IT
AFFECTS ALL OF US INTO THE
AFFECT OUR MEMBERS AS WELL AS
THEY GO BACK TO TRY TO EXPLAIN
TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS. BY
CERTAIN SCHOOLS ARE NOT BEING
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. SO I'M NOT
SURE. HOW THESE DECISIONS ARE
MADE I SHOULD KNOW BUT I DON'T.
IN SOME ROOM SOMEWHERE- WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY MEMBERS AND I'VE HAD
SEVERAL MEMBERS ASKED ME ABOUT
THE NOT THE FUNDING OF NINE
CLASSROOMS IN THIS NEW PROPOSAL
THEY WERE UPSET OVER THE FIRST
RIPPLES OF SO WE'VE MADE SOME
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF. A DEAL
WITH A BRICK AND MORTAR KIND OF
SET UP SITUATION WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE EQUALLY GREAT AND I THINK
AS AS A STATE WE RECOGNIZE AND
SOMETIMES WE THINK THAT
DISTANCE LEARNING IS. IS NOT AS
RIGOROUS AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT BUT I THINK WE
PROBABLY LEARNED THAT IN THE
LAST. FOR THREE FOUR MONTHS AS
WE HAVE ENGAGED IN DISTANCE
LEARNING THAT TO DO IT AND TO
DO IT RIGHT IS IT TAKES A LOT
OF TIME AND ALLOW STAFF TIME. A
LOT OF RESOURCES AND YET WE'RE
CUTTING OFF THE RESOURCES TO A
METHOD OF ALL INSTRUCTION THAT
WE AS A STATE HAVE EMBRACED OUT
OF NECESSITY. AT THIS POINT AND
PROBABLY WILL HAVE MORE OF OUR
KIDS NOT IN THE CLASSROOM AND
IN THE CLASSROOM TIS YEAR AND
IT WOULD NOT FUNDING TO TRY TO
SCHOOLS. WHO ARE DOING THIS
HARD WORK- I THINK AS A AS A
COMMITTEE WE SHOULD RETHINK
THIS PROPOSAL THAT'S COMING TO
US NOW BECAUSE IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA. COULD
NOT FUND THE SCHOOLS. IN
CALIFORNIA ALWAYS FINDS ITS
KIDS EVEN IF IT EVERYBODY GETS
A MORE OUT THEY GET THAT THEY
GET THE FUNDING THEY KNOW WHAT
IT IS. SO. THANK YOU DON'T WANT
WITH ANY OTHER COMMENTS. FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THE SIR NONE
LET'S GO TO SB. EIGHT THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LIQUOR SMART
WITH THE LIST OF AN OFFICE ARE
YOU ABLE TO HELP ME. YOUR YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU I'LL BE
PRESENTING SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WERE AGREED LINE THAT OF
JUVENILE FROM THE STATE TO THE
COUNTY UNDER SB EIGHT TO THREE
D. A. J. WERE STOP INTAKE
BEGINNING JULY TO TWENTIETH.
AND THE A FINAL DATE OF THIS
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE ANY USE REMAINING AND DJ
AS OF THAT DATE WOULD BE. WE
TALKED TO THE COUNTIES OF
JURISDICTION THREE YOU COULD BE
HOUSING THE EXISTING TYPES OF.
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES
INCLUDING GYM OUT HOMES RANCHES
IN CAMPS AS WELL AS A NEW TYPE
OF FACILITY SECURE YOU
TREATMENT FACILITIES. WHICH
WOULD BE A TOP AUTHORIZED UNDER
THIS BILL AND WOULD BE INTENDED
TO CREATE A NEW TYPE OF.
FACILITY FOR THAT WOULD PROVIDE
PROGRAMMING AND TREATMENT TO
USE EDUCATED FOR VIOLENT OR
SERIOUS OFFENSES. THAT BILL
WOULD ALSO PROVIDES. OF MAKE
CHANGES TO DISCARD THE
PLACEMENT OF YOUTH AND ADULT
FACILITIES- CALL ME WHEN YOU
USE CASES TRANSFERRED FROM THE
JUVENILE COURT TO A CRIMINAL
COURT AND IN THE U. THE
SENTENCED TO PRISON. DJJ WOULD
HOUSE THAT YOU'VE UNTIL THEY
ARE RELEASED AGE OF EIGHTEEN
AND CAN BE TRANSFERRED TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
CDCR. UNDER SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE WHEN DID I STOP INTAKE
COUNTIES WOULD HOUSE ANY YOUTH.
WHO WERE SENTENCED TO PRISON
UNTIL THEY ARE EIGHTEEN AND
THEN WHEN THEY ARE EIGHTEEN
THEY'LL BE TRANSFERRED T CDC
ARE AND WE NEED TO PAY THE CDC
OURS MARGINAL COST FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE SENTENCE. WE
KNOW THAT CURRENTLY COUNTIES DO
NOT PAY A FEE FOR YOU SENT TO
PRISON BUT THEY DO PAY A FEE
FOR YOUTH COMMITTED TO DJJ. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THIS REALIGNMENT.
THROUGHOUT THE BLOCK GRANT. A
ONE TIME INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT.
AND A REGIONAL COMPETITIVE
GRANT. IN ORDER TO ACCESS THESE
GRANT FUNDS COUNTY WOULD NEED
TO FOLLOW CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS.
INCLUDING SUBMITTING PLANS TO
THE STATE FOR APPROVAL ON HOW
THE FUNDING WOULD BE UTILIZED.
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. YOU CAN YOU MAY
WANT ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH JUSTICE WOULD
BE CREATED UNDER THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY I WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE TASKS. SUCH AS
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT DATA
COLLECTION AND ALL JUVENILE
JUSTICE FACILITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ASSIGNED TO THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS ESCC. WE KNOW THAT
HAVING CONCERNS RAISED IN THE
PAST ABOUT THE SEC'S ABILITY
DEPRIVE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT. FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE CRIME PREVENTION ACT JJ
CPA WAS HINDERED BY INADEQUATE
AND OUTDATED PLANS. WHICH
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
TO THE SEC ANNUALLY THAT
LIMITED OVERSIGHT BY THE SEC
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS. PHYSICALLY
THE AUDITOR NOTED THAT THE SEC
LOCKED THE THIRTY TO. COMPEL
COUNTIES TO COMPLY WITH THE JJC%
REQUIREMENTS IN ADDITION PSEC
TO NOT REVIEW THE PLANS COUNTY
SUBMITTED FOR ACCURACY. OR
REQUIRE THE COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
DETAILS ON ANY CHANGES THEY
MADE TO THE PLANS. OTHER
ENTITIES HAVE ALSO BEEN RATE
HAVE ALSO RAISED CONCERNS
REGARDING THE LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
PROVIDED BY PSPC INCLUDING
JOURNALISTS AND THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE. THANK YOU I HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU TO PROPONENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE DISCUSSION
AND HARD WORK THAT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS PROPOSAL
I'M FOR. WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH- SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE AND THAT BOTH FISCAL AND
POLICY- AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANKS. THANK YOU
WE ARE NOT TALKING ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANDYOU
KNOW I MAY START WITH JUST A
PROCESS QUESTION I'M TRYING O
UNDERSTAND IS THIS THE FIRST
HEARING THIS BILL HAS HAD- IN
ANY COMMITTEE AT ALL. THIS YEAR.
WAS HEARD IN THE SUB FIVE
HEARING IN IN JULY. CAN WE. I'M
REALLY TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A FRAMING QUESTION BEFORE
WE GET INTO THE POLICY AND THE
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE
BILL AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S THE
GOVERNOR WHO PUT OUT AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER EXTENDING THE
DEADLINE FROM JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SO I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL AT ALL. IF WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THAT EXTENSION.
SO THE PROBLEM PROPOSALS FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ALL THAT
D. O. RESPONDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL. IS
INTENDED TO OPERATIONALIZE
BASED ON THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO REALIGN DJJ BUT THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL IS IN THE MAY
REVISION FROM THE GOVERNOR.
JUST TO CLARIFY PROPOSAL THAT
WE ARE HEARING TODAY IS THE
LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL NOT THE
COVERS. YES SO THE EXTENSION
YOU'RE DESCRIBING- GOES BACK TO
THE GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL OWES
ALL THAT WAS APPROVED AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AND CONTINUED AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS
YEAR. TO MOVE THE STATE LEVEL
DJJ OVER TO THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY ANIME
REVISION- AFTER SORT OF THE
PANDEMIC- AND LOOKING AT SORT
OF HOW WE BEST USE OUR
RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE AND
MAKE A GOOD POLICY OUTCOMES WE
DECIDED THAT IT ACTUALLY WOULD
BE BEST TO MOVE. YOU WITH- AWAY
FROM THE STATE LEVEL TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO THEY CAN BE
CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
HAVE IMPROVED OUTCOMES- AND BE
CLOSER TO COMMUNITY FOR RE
ENTRY SERVICES IN THOSE TYPES
OF THINGS. SO THE PROPOSAL
TODAY IS IN- RELATION TO THAT
REALIGNMENT NOT THE SHIFT
BETWEEN- SEEK THE CDC OUR
OPERATOR OVERSEEING DJJ AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WHICH
IS WHAT THAT. EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAS IN RELATION TO. IF I CAN
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATORS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE- AND AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE I UNDERSTOOD THIS TO
BE UNDER HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AND WAS SURPRISED
THEN THAT IT'S HARD UNDER SUB
FIVE AND NOT SUB ONE AND SO I
WILL BE. BE FORTHCOMING IN
SHARING I HAVE MORE THAN MY
FAIR SHARE OF QUESTIONS
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE
FROM THE SUMMARY THAT I SEE WE
HAVE. A NEW OFFICE WE ARE
TRANSFERRING REGULATIONS AND
FUNDING. WE HAVE A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA WE DISCUSS A NEW IT
SYSTEM AND WE'RE COMMITTING
OURSELVES TO. OUT HERE FUNDING
OF OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT HAVING SOME OF
THE PRELIMINARY QUESTIONS ASKED
AND SO I'D LIKE TO JUST
UNDERSTAND. WHAT OUR STATED
GOALS AND METRICS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. HELLO HELLO
HELLO JENNIFER ANSWER OR DO YOU
WANT DO YOU HAVE TO DO ONE
AFTER FOR SOME SORT. THE BLACK
GIVEN THAT THE- BEING DISCUSSED
TODAY IS- THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSAL I AS I. I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO RESPOND. ON JENNIFER CAME
WITH THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE SUB FIVE- THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL JUST
THIS IS STEP BACK- THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTED THE
TRANSFER. OF DJJ FROM CDC ARE
TWO EIGHT HHS- WE- ARE NOW
BEING RESPONSIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE MAY
REVISION TO STOP THAT TRANSFER
AND SO WE- ACTUALLY STOP THE
FUNDING TRANSFERS WEALTH FROM
CDC R. DHHS IN THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUDGET- AGREEMENT
AND- HAVE AGREED TO WORK OVER
THE SUMMER TO COME UP WITH A
WAY TO OPERATIONALIZE. THIS OP
REALIGNMENT IN A MINUTE IN A
WAY THAT- ADDRESS IS KIND OF
THE MEMBERS CONCERNS AROUND
DOING THE ALIGNMENT THE RIGHT
WAY WITH PROPER OVERSIGHT. AND
SO SOME OF THE PIECES THAT YOU
SEE IN THERE ARE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN COVERED BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN PAST YEARS-
AROUND WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST-
KIND OF INTERVENTION AND- OF
THE LEVEL OF RESOURCES THE
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT NEEDED FOR
THE COUNTIES TO TAKE ON THE
SYSTEM. IN A WAY THAT- AS DR
WEBER HAS STATED THAT WE DON'T
GET A JUSTICE BY GEOGRAPHY
SITUATION- SO THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDES- SEVERAL
ELEMENTS- LUKE. ALLUDED TO A
FOR. THAT KINDA LOOKS AT- THE
COUNTY SHARE THE YOUTH
POPULATION- ADJUDICATIONS FOR
SEVEN OH SEVEN B. OFFENSES
WHICH ARE THE OFFENSES THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. TO
BE SENT TO THE J. J. AS WELL AS
PRIOR DJJ USAGE WE ALSO
INCLUDE- SECURE A ONE TIME
SECURE FACILITY- GRANT PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
COUNTIES CURRENTLY YOU MAY NEED
TO UPGRADE THEIR CURRENT-
JUVENILE FACILITIES IN ORDER TO
TAKE ON THIS NEW POPULATION AND
THE FINAL FINALLY THERE'S SOME
COMPETITIVE FUNDING. THAT'S
PROVIDED FOR EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH BASED PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING
JUVENILE JUSTICE- ALONG WITH
THAT WE- THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF AN OFFICE
OF YOUTH JUSTICE. WHICH IS ALL
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ACTUALLY.
UGH IN THE MINORITY IN TERMS OF
NOT HAVING A CENTRALIZED STATE
LEVEL- LEADERSHIP AGENCY THAT
KIND OF DELVES INTO JUVENILE
JUSTICE ISSUES AND CURRENTLY-
WITH THE REALIGNMENT OF DJJ THE
STATE IS FUNDAMENTALLY GETTING
OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN TERMS OF- WHAT. THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN THE
STATE'S ROLE WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD ONCE YOU THEIR-
REALIGNED SORRY NUMBER WASN'T
EXPECTING TO SPEAK SO MUCH. AND
I WILL SHARE. WANTING TO WORK
TOWARDS MAKING SURE THAT YOUTH
ARE GIVEN AS MUCH CHANCE AS WE
CAN TO REHABILITATE AND BELIEVE
THERE IS A LOT OF LOGIC BETWEEN.
PUTTING IT UNDER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THAT I'M- TRYING
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING
THAT OCCURRED AND I'M SORRY FOR
IT BUT THE BILL THAT AMENDED
YESTERDAY AND WE'RE SITTING
HERE TODAY ASKING SOME
QUESTIONS ON IT WE'RE GOING TO
BE ASKED TO. VOTE ON THIS HERE
SHORTLY AND I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE KICKING THE
TIRES BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT A TRANSITION
LOOKS LIKE SURE AND DOCTOR
ARAMBULA- THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
JUSTICE WILL BE CREATED UNDER
THE HHS UMBRELLA- WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE EXPERTISE
THAT'S IN THAT AGENCY AND I
THINK THAT'S- A- BOTH SENTIMENT
AND A PRIORITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXPRESSED URINE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S THE MOST. APPROPRIATE
ENTITY TO PROVIDE KIND OF THE
STATE LEVEL GUIDANCE GUIDANCE.
WHAT WE- IT LIKE A- AS LUCAS.
IF IADD ON ABOUT TRANSIT AREA
ED I THE AS EIGHT TWENTY THREE
THAT TRANSITION BE WHAT THE
CLOSURE OF THE WOULD NOT HAPPEN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE BOTH FOR
THE SUBJECT UNTIL AND THEN FOR
THE FINAL CLOSURE IN DECEMBER
AND THE REASON FOR THAT DELAY
IS TO GIVE COUNTY SOME TIME TO
DEVELOP THAT OUR RESOURCES SO
THAT THEY ARE PREPARED FOR THIS
TRANSITION BEFORE THE TAKE ON
RESPONSIBILITIES- IT DOES ALSO
INCLUDE. FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
IF THEY CHOOSE TO WITHDRAW
COUNTIES BUT WITH ALL USED ONLY
WITHIN THAT DATE AND SO THEY
ARE PREPARED TO DO SO THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO START DRYING
DOWN SOME OF THAT FUNDING THAT%
BE AVAILABLE FOR THOSE USED TO
HELP. OFFSET THE COST. THANK WE
THAT CAN ARE. LET ME ASK IT
DIFFERENTLY WHAT STEPS THE IN
TAKE TAKEN TO COLLABORATE WITH
KEY STAKEHOLDERS FOR THIS
PROPOSAL HAVE WE TALKED WITH
COUNTY IS ABOUT THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO RECEIVE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY. ALL YES WE HAD
A SIGNIFICAN COLLABORATION WITH
THE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT'S ASSOCIATION AND-
THAT COUNTY ASSOCIATION AS WELL
ON THE PROPOSAL I THINK THAT
THE TWO MAIN ELEMENTS HERE THAT
HAVE IT MAKE US FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
REALIGNMENT IS THAT- THERE WAS
A SIGNIFICANT REALIGNMENT DONE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OF
JUVENILES AND APPEARS TO HAVE
BEEN- VERY PRETTY SUCCESSFUL
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT YOU-
STAYING CLOSE TO HOME ACTUALLY
HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES- BECAUSE
OF REENTRY SERVICES BEING
CLOSER TO THEIR FAMILY- TO KIND
OF ILLUSTRATE SORT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THERE WAS ELEVEN THOUSAND
YOUTH IN JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES LOCALLY NOW THERE IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IF THERE
WAS THIRTY SIX HUNDRED A
DECREASE OF ALMOST 70% SO IT'S
THOSE THINGS IN MIND- IN
ADDITION TO OUR- YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT COLLABORATION HERE
WITH THOSE ENTITIES THAT HAS A
STILL COMFORTABLE THAT THEY ARE
READY TO TAKE IT ON UNDER OUR
PROPOSAL- I BELIEVE THEY'RE
THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL AS A
RUSE AS CONSTRUCTED AND SB.
EIGHT EIGHT TWENTY THREE CELL
YES JENNIFER COMMITTEE COME
INTO THAT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
CONTRARY THAT WE'RE HEARING A
PROPOSAL THAT THE SEEMS LIKE
THE COUNTIES ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO. THIS IS SO THE K. HAVE
WEIGHED AND I THINK THEY'VE
PROVIDED CRITIQUE ON BOTH
PROPOSALS- PART OF THE REASON
WHY WE CROSS THE BILL WAS THAT
WE CAN HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
AND WE'VE- LET THEM KNOW THAT-
NEGOTIATIONS ARE ONGOING- SO WE
ARE INCORPORATING THEIR
FEEDBACK. ON THE JUVENILE COURT
JUDGES ASSOCIATION DID SUBMIT A
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE SUPERBOWL PUZZLES-
ARM SAYING THAT WAS A BALANCED
APPROACH AND IT ACTUALLY
PROVIDES A TIMELINE THAT'S
WORKABLE- TO IMPLEMENT THESE
CHANGES ONE OTHER THING I'D
LIKE TO ADD IS THAT CURRENTLY.
UP ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND YOUNG
PEOPLE EVERY YEAR ARE JUDICATA
FOR THE SEVEN OH SEVEN B.
OFFENSES- WHICH WOULD MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR DJJ. ONLY TWO
HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE ARE ACTUALLY SENT
TO DJJ SO COUNTIES ARE ALREADY
KEEPING ABOUT 97% OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE- LOCALLY AND SO-
CONSIDERING HOW SMALL THE
POPULATION IS- I THINK WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE.
WE FEEL THAT COUNTIES WOULD BE
EQUIPPED- TO TAKE ON THIS
POPULATION. HOW WILL BE
ADMINISTRATION THEM PLAN TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES THAT DO NOT
HAVE CAPACITY. FOR THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT OF YOUTH.
SO I THINK- THAT WE WOULD ALLOW
COUNTIES TO SORT OF WORK
AMONGST THEMSELVES TO FIGURE I
DETERMINE THE BEST SITUATION
FOR THEMSELVES TO FIND
TREATMENT SERVICES FOR YOU I
THIS IS AN EXISTING PRACTICE
TODAY- AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
AREAS OF OUR PROPOSAL- THAT WE
ORIGINALLY HAD CONTEMPLATED A
LOT MORE STRUCTURE TO AROUND.
SEX OFFENDER TREATMENT IN
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT IN THIS
YOU KNOW STOP WATCHING THIS-
HUBS AND HAVING- YOU KNOW VERY
SPECIFIC SORT OF FUNDING
STREAMS AND CRITERIA AROUND
THAT BUT AFTER A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IT WAS YOU CAN
CLEAR THAT- THEY NEED THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE WHAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
AND SOMETIMES MAYBE EVEN NOT.
THAT THE- SORT OF. FEELING THE
NAME OF BEING AHUB- BUT
FINDING THOSE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE
THE CAPACITY THAT HAVE THE
INTEREST IN PUTTING THAT ON AND
THEN ALLOWING THEM TO TRANSFER
MY FUNDS AMONGST THEMSELVES
ABOUT. HOW TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES LOCALLY. WELL I THINK
THE FIVE. YOU KNOW WE HEARD
ABOUT JUSTICE BY GEOGRAPHY
EARLIER AND SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO. MAKE SURE WE HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A REALIGNMENT
BLOCK GRANT. HOW HOW WILL WE
MAKE SURE THAT THIS FUNDING
FORMULA ENSURES AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION THE COUNTIES.
BASED ON WHAT WAS JUST
MENTIONED. SO IF I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT FUNDING- DOT UNDER SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE. THAT BLOCK
GRANT WOULD BE PROVIDED THROUGH
A FORMULA WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
MULTIPLE FACTORS INCLUDING THAT
TOTAL YOUTH POPULATION IN THE
COUNTY. AND TALK YOUR IS THE
TOTAL USE OF DJJ IN RECENT
YEARS. BY THAT COUNTY AND ALSO
THE TOTAL EDUCATION FOR H.
ELIGIBLE IT WOULD ALSO
GUARANTEE A MINIMUM LEVEL OF
FUNDING. FOR COUNTIES SOUTH
COUNTY THAT HAVE LOW NUMBERS OF
EDUCATION'S WOULD BE GUARANTEED
TO SOME STABLE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING- THE OTHER GRANT
PROGRAMS IT WOULD ALSO HELP
COUNTIES DEVELOP THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THESE YOUTH. AND EIGHT
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CONTRACT BETWEEN
COUNTY SAID THEY WOULD NOT BE
RESTRICTED JUST IN OUR OWN
THEIR RESOURCES WITHIN THE
COUNTY THERE WOULD ALSO BE
ALLOWED TO. CONTRACT WITH OTHERCOUNTIES AND COULD THEY COULD
USE THE FUNDING PROVIDED
THROUGH THE GRANTS TO HELP.
COVER THOSE COSTS. I TO BE
CLOAKED BUT SOMETIME I CAN'T MY-
THIS FEEL LIKE A PUTTING THE
BEFORE THE HORSE. AND I WONDER
SOMETIMES HOW WE- MAKE SURE THE
POLICIES ARE WELL VETTED BEFORE
WERE. HAVING TO EVALUATE THEM
ASK QUESTIONS AND VOTE ON I'M
IN THE MATTER OF HOURS. AND SO
I'M WONDERING AGAIN IF I CAN
START WITH MY FIRST QUESTION.
WHAT'S THE URGENCY AND RUSH TO
DO THIS SINCE THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS PUSH THIS OFF UNTIL NEXT
YEAR. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
ASK THE APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS
HAVE STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT
HAVE DELIBERATIONS BECAUSE- IF
IT CAUGHT ME A LITTLE BIT BY
SURPRISE AND FEEL. FEELS A
LITTLE CONCERNING TO ME THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS
READY AND THAT- WE COULD
BENEFIT FROM MORE TIME WORKING
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND SO WOULD
LIKE TO. SEE IF YOU HAVE A-
SLIGHTLY CHANGE RESPONSIBLE.
I'M SO JUST TO KIND OF
REITERATE REITERATE THAT THE
PROPOSAL ORIGINALLY CAME FROM
THE GOVERNOR I WILL SAY THAT IN
OUR SUB COMMITTEE AND I THINK
IN PRIOR YEARS AND THE POLICY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. THERE
HAVE BEEN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE CLOSURE OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND REALIGNMENT SO DID THIS
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN ONGOING
FOR AT LEAST A DECADE- AND I
THINK PART OF THE REASON- THAT
WERE READY TO HAVE IT NOW IS
THAT THE POPULATION HAS GOTTEN
SO SMALL. UNFORTUNATELY THE
MOST RECENTRECIDIVISM REPORT-
THAT I HAVE ACCESS TO STILL
SHOWS AND OVER 73% RECIDIVISM
RATE AND THE STATE CURRENTLY
SPENDS APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YOUNG PERSON STATED THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN SOME FISCAL REASONS
AS TO WHY THE GOVERNOR- CHOSE
THIS MOMENT- TO DO THE
REALIGNMENT- I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK. ON THEIR BEHALF BUT I
WILL SAY FOR- SOME OF THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED THIS IS A POLICY THAT
HAS BEEN KIND OF CRAFTED OVER
THE YEARS. AND SO THERE ARE
PIECES OF IT THAT HAVE BEEN
VETTED- FOR SOME TIME. I WOULD
JUST TO SORT OF CARE THAT TO
SUGGEST JUST THIS WAS FIRST
BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE NISS
MINISTRATION IN JANUARY OF LAST
YEAR AND THE FIRST BUDGET- NOT
EXACTLY IN THIS FORM WITH THE
MOVING OF DJJ SO WE HAD A YEAR
LONG DISCUSSION LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
REACH. AGREEMENT WITH SOME OF
THE DETAILS BUT DID AGREE TO
MOVE THE AGENCY THIS YEAR THEY
CAME BACK WITH A- REVISED
PROPOSAL TO NOT MOVE IT TO THE
AGENCY BUT THEN. MOVE IT TO THE
COUNTIES IN SO AT LEAST. L.
WITHIN THIS CAN. THERE'S BEEN A
PER SICK. AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION
ON ON THIS ON THIS IDEA WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION FOUR I
THINK THE BETTER PART OF ALMOST
TWO TWO YEARS- I THINK YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN. BUT I WILL
JUST SAY THAT JUST BECAUSE WE
HAVE. GREATER STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
WILL HAVE STAKEHOLDER
AGREEMENT. AND SO- AND YOU'RE
WELL AWARE OF THAT FOR MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT THE COMPLICATED
ISSUES YOU DO WITHIN YOUR SUB
COMMITTEE- AND SO I WOULD SAY-
I KNOW THAT THIS- THERE'S A LOT
OF DETAIL COMING OUT. ON A FOR
YOU TO DIGEST BUT I WILL SAY
THIS IS THIS HAS BEEN- HERE THE
COMMITTEE HAS SPENT AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME ON THIS. WITH
ALL THE VARIOUS- STAKEHOLDERS
HAS BEEN TRYING TO ENGAGE. I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION- THIS
WAS AGAIN- BASED ON THEY WERE
TRYING TO PRESENT TRY TO HAVE A
RESOLUTION. ON THEIR ORIGINAL
JANUARY PROPOSAL THERE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL IS SOMETHING
THAT WE COMMITTED T TRY TO
RESOLVE BUT- BEFORE WE- CLOSED
OUT IN A BOX. AND I AM PLEASED
TO THE TIME AND WILL ALLOW TO
HAVE QUESTIONS THAT I WILL JUST.
AND OPINING. HISTORICALLY OUR
STATE GONE THROUGH DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING REALIGNMENT IN YEARS
AFTER A CENSUS. AND IT SEEMS
THAT THIS TYPE OF DISCUSSION IF
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
REALIGNING. RESPONSIBILITIES
AND FINDINGS BETWEEN STATE AND
COUNTIES. THAT THIS DECISION
AND DISCUSSION COULD BENEFIT
FROM A TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR.
BUT THAT'S- A CONVERSATION FOR
ANOTHER DAY SIMPLY JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT. I STILL NEED TO DO
A LOT MORE WORK AND WILL BE
WORKING WITH YOUR OFFICE TO GET
MANY MORE OF OUR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED- BEFORE I CAN FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS TRAILER
BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST. YEAH I'M I WANT TO.
THANK GO. MISS KIM AND OTHERS
FOR IT WE'VE HAD QUITE A BIT OF
CONVERSATION ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE- AND- NOT JUST THIS YEAR
BUT LAST YEAR AS WELL LOTS OF
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT LOTS OF
PROPOSALS OF AND EVEN MORE
RECENTLY I GUESS ABOUT A WEEK
AGO WE HAD A ANOTHER HEARING ON
THIS MATTER WITH REGARD TO
THIS. LOTS OF STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION I THINK THE TWO
HOUSES ARE PRETTY MUCH IN LINE
WITH EACH OTHER AS TO WHAT WE
WANT WHAT WE THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN- WE'VE CONSISTENTLY SAID
THAT- IF WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
DJJ SHOULD BE ALWAYS BE FOR THE
BETTER. OKAY THEN SIMPLY MOVING
AT A COST CENTER FROM ONE PLACE
TO THE NEXT THAT IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF WHO WRITES A CHECK OF
WHAT THE PROGRAM IS AND WHAT
OUTCOMES ARE AND WHAT WE KNOWS
BEST PRACTICES WITH REGARDS TO
HANDLE HOW TO HANDLE LIKE YOU.
AND I AND SURE THAT THERE WAS
SOME EQUITY AND SOME FAIRNESS
ACROSS THE BOARD SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE AREAS WHERE- IT'S
A COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WOULD NOT AS INTERESTED IN
YOUNG PEOPLE AT SOME OTHER
PLACE WAS A MESS THEREFORE YOU
KNOW IT'S GREAT TO GO TO.
BRITAIN MODERATE BECAUSE YOU'RE
GONNA GET A CERTAIN KIND OF
HERE VERSUS IN THE VALLEY WHERE
YOU MAY NOT GET MUCH OF
pOF THE DIFFERENCES IN THE
DISPARITY AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE FEEL OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES VERY IMPORTANT THAT
GOES ACROSS AGENCIES- WE MAKE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT A MATTER
OF PICKING UP A PROGRAM HERE
AND PUTTING IT OVER THERE WITH
THE SAME PEOPLE. BECAUSE YOU
GET THE SAME RESULTS YOU KNOW
THAT WE NEED A BETTER RESULTS
AND SO WE HAD THINK AS A
BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
SENATE WE FAIRLY BEEN VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE WANT AYE
I'VE BEEN CLEAR WITH THE
THERE'S THERE THERE OF CHAIR OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OVER THERE
AND WE'RE PRETTY MUCH TOGETHER.
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK THESE
DIFFERENCES OUT WITH
ADMINISTRATION WITH REGARD
SUPPORT IT LOOKS LIKE TO BE
VERY HONEST AND UP AND SO WE
HAVE- IT'S THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT HAS COME FORTH
WITHOUT ANY DETAILS INITIALLY
JUST MOVING IT. AND SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM THE
ADVOCATES AND FLUSH IT OUT AND
TRY TO DO SOME KIND OF THE
THINGS THAT MAKE SENSE FOR OUR
KIDS SO WE'RE STILL OUT HERE
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE KIND OF
THE SKELETAL. THING THAT'S THE
WE SOME MORE INFORMATION. BUT
BUT IT'S BEEN A LOT OF. IT IS
UNFAIR FOR US. YOU KNOW.
INITIATIVE TO BE MOVE. THAT WAS
AND THEN WE- ARE WORKING ON ALL
OF THE DEAL A LITTLE MOVED BACK
THEN SO BE OF ME ALSO. IS A
ELSE. SO STILL WORKING ON IT
AND KNOW WE WERE COMMITTED TO
IT BUT- IT WAS. WHAT HAPPENS AT
THE END. OF THE DETAIL OF WE'VE
BEEN. TO OFFER. THAT SO THAT IS
NOT. JUST A TRAIN. OVER ONE. IN
A TO THE NET. AND GET THE SAME
RESULTS AND IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE OF MAKES NUYS PRESS. BUT
IT DOESN'T MAKE. NICE OUTCOMES.
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING AND
THIS IS. A REALLY. US SKELETON
IDEA THIS IS BECAUSE OF WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE. BUT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
WHATEVER WE- EVENTUALLY
OPERATIONALIZEAND FUN.
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN BE PROUD
OF FOR THE KIDS AND THEY WERE
TAKING. IN CONSIDERATION THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED AND HOPEFULLY ENGAGE
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT- WE
DON'T WANT TO SYSTEM THE SIMPLY
BECOMES A PIPELINE TO PRISON.
AND YOU KNOW SO THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SOME IT MAKES
GETS BETTER SO. WE'VE GOT LOTS
OF MEETINGS ABOUT THE CAMPUS.
OKAY IN THE END. AND I'LL- THE
STAFF ON BOTH SIDES OF HOUSES
THAT HAD. ENORMOUS READINGS
ADVOCATE AND CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IT AND SO- WE'LL TO. IF
THIS YEAR MIGHT IF WE TOGETHER
ON THE DETAILS OF MY ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW. IN PLACE IT'S FIRST.
TO SAY THE LEAST. BUT WE ARE
COMMITTED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S DONE RIGHT. THANK YOU
ROBERT MISTER COOPER THIS IS AN
EIGHTY SIX PAGE TRAILER BILL
AND DURING COVER NINETEEN THIS
IS LINE WITH GOOD INTENTIONS
THE PUTTING OUR FRESHEST TRAP
COUNTY TO USE ITS ADVANTAGE THE
WORST POSSIBLE TIME. FOR
ANYTHING FOR MAYBE ONE I WISH
LEARN THIS LESSON I WAS PART OF
AB ONE OH NINE AND AB ONE NINE
HAS BEEN A FAILURE- AND GOT THE
INMATES AT A STATE PRISON
BECAUSE THE OVERCROWDING BUT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES DOING
FIFTY DIFFERENT THINGS. THE
RECIDIVISM RATE AS HIGH AS HELL
IN THE COUNTY JAILS NO ONE
KNOWS WHAT IT IS THE GOVERNOR
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IT IS FINANCE
ANYONE CAN TELL YOU WHAT IT IS.
EVEN THE SOCIALLY JUSTICE
MOTIVATED CHIEFS WHO WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT THERE THEY
OPPOSE THE BILL RIGHT NOW A.
ISSUES THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
TOUGH BUT NOTHING ON THIS BILL.
THE X. REALIZE OF THIS FRAUD
POPULAR. FACILITY SPACE.
RESOURCE ACQUISITION. PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT. PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
YOUTH. AND FACILITY RESIGNED
FOR TREATMENT. HE GOES TO A
COMPETITIVE GRANT FOR THE
COUNTIES. SO WITH DJJ RIGHT
NOW. THEY'VE A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED SEX OFFENDER
PROGRAM. THAT'S ONE AWARDS IT
DOES A GREAT JOB IT SOLVES IT.
SO HOW YOU CAN TAKE UP TO FIFTY
COUNTY TO REPLICATE THAT AWARD
WINNING PROGRAM. YOU CAN'T DO
THAT. SO I'M JUST THINKING
ABOUT AND IN A ONE HERE THIS
COMMITTEES HAVE YOU SEE. ABOVE
US WHO THOUGHT ABOUT THIS. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE IT WASN'T THOUGHT
OUT VERY CLEARLY. ESPECIALLY
SMALL NUMBERS YOU GOT FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY SO YOU GO TO
PLACES. THAT HAVE BEEN ALL
THESE THE U. S. INFOS BECHTEL
SAME COUNTIES WE CAME FROM.
THIS SMALL COUNTIES IS ONE
COUNTY GONNA HIRE PSYCHOLOGISTS
A CLINICIAN TO DEAL WITH THESE
KIDS. THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
WHEN HE WAS SMALL POPULATION
THAT MAY ONLY BE FIVE KIDS FROM
FROM FINANCE BOOK ABOUT YOU
KNOW OBVIOUS THE PUBLIC'S IS
GOING DOWN. WOULD YOU HALL
GUESS WHAT. IF YOU ROB SOMEONE
WITH A GUN YOU DON'T STAY IN
JUVENILE HALL IF YOU RAPE
SOMEBODY. YOU GET OUT AND GET
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL WITH A
VICTIM YOU RAPED. YOU SHOOT
SOMEONE YOU COULD OUT RIGHT NOW
SO NOT A LOT OF KIDS IN
JUVENILE HALL BECAUSE- OF THE
WAY THINGS HAPPEN RELEASED
PEOPLE- ALSO YOU TALK ABOUT
THESE FACILITIES WHEN THEY GO
TO. A PROBATION. UNDER DJJ
DIGIDAY. CONTROLS THE SCHOOLS.
THE HEALTH. ENVIRONMENT UNDER
THE DJJ UMBRELLA. MIDDLE
COUNTIES YOUR DEAL WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SO A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS TO IT. IT'S JUST LOW
NUMBERS. THAT'S THE THING
PEOPLE DON'T FIGURE OUT OUT TO
GOT KIDS IN THERE THAT ARE
COMMITTEES ADULTS A SIXTEEN OR
SEVENTEEN. YOU TALK ABOUT
HAVING KIDS BEING ALLOWED IN
THERE TWO OR TWENTY THREE OR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD HOW DO WE
DO THAT SEPARATE YOU UNITS
STAFFING THEY'RE NOT MANY GIRLS
IN THERE SO OBVIOUSLY IF YOU
HAVE GIRLS IN THERE YOUR COSTS
ARE GOING TO RISE
EXPONENTIALLY. BECAUSE BECAUSE
A LOT MORE STAFFING THEIR VERY
TIME INTENSIVE WITH THAT. SO IT
I MEAN THERE'S SO MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT DEJECTED
CURRENT PROGRAMS INCLUDE YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION A TREATMENT
FOR SIX SESSIONS AGGRESSOR
AGGRESSION REPLACEMENT TRAINING
ONE HOUR THREE TIMES A WEEK
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE THIRTY NINE SESSIONS
COUNTERPOINT THIRTY THREE
SESSIONS. SIX BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT A LOT OF THINGS THAT
EFFECTIVE SO IF ANYBODY THINKS
THEY'RE GOING TO COUNTIES IT'S
GOING TO BE A BETTER PROGRAM
YOU HAD EXAMINED YOUR FRIGGIN
CRAZY IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN AT
ALL LIKE I SAID IT AND ALSO
LOOK AT THE COUNTY WILL HAPPEN
AB ONE OH NINE THEY'VE BEEN
SUED BY THE PRISON LAW OFFICE
THEY'VE ALL BEEN SUED OVER
MEDICAL CONDITIONS WHICH SEES
THE AUGUST TWO FOUR AND BUILT A
HOSPITAL STOCKTON. CONDITIONS A
WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS THAT C.
C. WENT THROUGH FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. THAT ACCOUNT IS GOING
THROUGH. THE PROCESS POPULATION
IN JUVENILE HALL. IT'S THE SAME
THING. IT'S FAILURE IF I GO
BACK LOOK AB ONE ONLINE WHAT
WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T WORK NO
ONE'S DONE THAT. ESPECIALLY AT
THIS TIME RIGHT NOW IT'S GOING
TO TAKE THREE YEARS THIS IS.
INCREMENTALLY TWENTY THREE WILL
GUESS WHAT. THIS BUDGET CRISIS
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW. IS GOING
OFF THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS MAYBE
NEXT THREE YEARS. SO IT'S JUST
IT'S THE HAVES AND HAVE NOTS.
YOU KNOW AND IT REALLY BECOMES
THESE KIDS WE CAN JUST DROP
KIDS ON THE DOORSTEP WITH A BAG
OF CASH AND WALK AWAY. IN ALL
COUNTIES AHEAD OF THE CURVE
WHEN IT COMES TO ADULT AND
JUVENILE REHABILITATION. SO
IT'S I MEAN SO I GUESS FOR
FINANCE. WITH ALL THE ACCOLADES
DJJ HAS GARNERED OVER THE YEARS.
HOW DO YOU CORRELATE THE TWO
WITH THE DROP OFF GOING TO
COUNTIES. CAN YOU TELL ME THAT.
YEAH I THINK THAT THE
MOTIVATING FACTOR HERE OR WAS
TWO FOLD EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATING
THAT YOU'D DO BEST WHEN THEY'RE
LOW CLOSE TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES- AND THEN
SECOND PULLED WAS THE SUCCESS
THAT COUNTIES HAD IN THE FIRST
JUVENILE- REALIGNMENT FROM THE
STATE IN. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
AND AS I DISCUSSED THAT
JUVENILE. DID POPULATION FROM
ELEVEN THOUSAND IN 200-072-3600
AND- TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ALMOST A 70% DECLINE- MO COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S ACTUALLY
HANDLE ALMOST THE ENTIRE
JUVENILE SYSTEM NOW WE ONLY
HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
YOUTH LEFT AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND IT WAS JUST IT WAS THINKING
ABOUT IT. IS IT BEST FOR THE
STATE TO HOLD ON TO THOSE YOU
OR LET THE COUNTIES WHO FOR
AREN'TDEALING WITH ALMOST ALL
THE YOUTH IN THE STATE AT THIS
POINT YEAH WELL TO EXPAND THEIR
CAPACITIES AND INTAKE ON
INCREMENTALLY A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND THEY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN AND
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT I AND I THINK
THAT MAKES US FEEL COMFORTABLE.
THAT THEY ARE THE APPROPRIATE
TO TAKE OUT THE THAT WORK ON
AND SO I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S A TWO PRONG THING HERE
THAT- YOU KNOW IT WAS THE
TIMING OF KOBE THINKING ABOUT A
FISHING USES A RESOURCE BUT
ALSO A LOT OF SUCCESS THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SEEING THAT USE
CAN BE- TO BETTER AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND AS IT RELATES TO. YOU
KNOW EVERY COUNTY HAVING REALLY
SPECIALIZED TREATMENT PROGRAMS
WE DON'T ENVISION THAT I DON'T
THINK THE COUNTIES ENVISIONED
THAT IT'S DAY ENVISION ACTUALLY
HAVING YOU KNOW SORT OF
REGIONAL PLACES WHERE THEY WILL
GO AND HAVE THAT SPECIALIZED
TREATMENT- THEY JUST DIDN'T
WANT THAT PRESCRIBED IN STATE
LAW AND HOW THAT WOULD BE BE
PUT TOGETHER BECAUSE- DIFFERENT
COUNTIES HAVE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES. AND THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY
TO DO WHAT WORKS BEST BASED ON
WHAT THEY HAVE SO THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS THE THINKING THERE-
AND I YOU KNOW WE I THINK IT
DEREK THERE IS MERIT TO THE
PROPOSAL WELL THE THINKING
SLIDE NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO. DJJ THE KIDS ARE THEY THAT
THE NUMBER SMALL. BUT ALSO THE
MOST VILE. PEOPLE THAT THE
ADDRESS THAT'S THAT'S THE-
ANALYSTS SAY BUT THAT'S- HIGH
PROFILE PEOPLE BETTER THEIR
SOUL AND IT IS PUSHED UP THE
COUNTIES THE COUNTIES ALL HAVE
THE SAME RESOURCES IT'S LIKE AB
ONE ONLINE. FOR STATE PRISONS.
IT'S ALL OVER THE BOARD WITH
THAT. SO THE CATTLE HAD DIDN'T
HAVE THE MONEY OF THE
CAPABILITIES TO DO IT. THAT'S
THAT WE DON'T GET THAT. LIKE I
SAID YOU KEEP GOING BACK TO
SMALL POPULATIONS ALL OVER ALL
OVER THE STATE. THOSE COUNTIES
ARE GONNA HIRE LOCAL PEOPLE ARE
EXPENSIVE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
SALARIES YOU PAY A LOT OF SONGS
FOR CLINICIAN. FOR A- THE-
PSYCHOLOGIST. IN THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE GONNA REPLICATE THOSE
PROGRAMS. LOOK AT THE MONEY AND
RESOURCES. DJJ HAS THESE
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE IT THEY
DON'T COME CLOSE. NOT A LEVEL
THE IN THE POPULATION HIGH
NEEDS POPULATION THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THEY DON'T HAVE IT.
AND FOR YOU GUYS SIT THERE SAY
THEY CAN DO IT IS REALLY
DISINGENUOUS. EVEN TO SERVICE
TO THE CITIZENS AND THOSE KIDS
THEY NEED HELP AND RIGHT NOW
THAT HOPE LIES AT DJJ. IT TOOK
YEARS TO GET THERE TO MAKE DJJ
THAT WAY. BECAUSE OF LAWSUITS
BECAUSE THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED. IF YOU GO BACK TO THE
COUNTIES THE SAME THING COULD
HAPPEN. IT'S LIKE IT'SLIKE A
LOOKING FOR A- IT'S LOOKING FOR
A PROBLEM. IT'S WORKING RIGHT
NOW. THE NUMBERS ARE LOW. IT
WORKS IT'S EFFECTIVE THESE KIDS
WE DON'T WANT THEM COMING BACK
CELESTE DOT REHABILITATION THIS
IS WHAT WORKS THIS IS GOOD
REHABILITATION THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS BEING AFFECTED WE
KNOW WITH THE METRICS THAT
PROVE IT. THE BENCHMARKS I
TALKED TO SOMEBODY TODAY WHO
HELPED CREATE THESE PROGRAMS.
AND THEY'RE LIKE WHY THEY
CHANGED TAKEN OUT OF THERE.
WE'RE THE EXPERTS. AN UPDATE TO
THE COUNTIES. AND IT'S JUST
IT'S A SCREW THAT UP IT IS A
CASH GRAB COMPETITIVE GRANTS
YOU GOT BETTER GRANT WRITERS IN
LA O SAN FRANCISCO THIS IS
SOMEBODY MODOC COUNTY OR
SOMEBODY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
GONNA GET MORE MONEY. HI THIS
IS A THIS IS HORRIBLE SO. I'VE
I'VE- BUT I'M DONE WITH THIS.
IF I MAY ASK A COUPLE OF POINTS
OF CLARIFICATION ON THE FUNDING
SIDE OF THE PROPOSAL OKAY. THE
ARMY REVISION PROPOSALS OUT
PROVIDING HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR YOUTH
WHICH WAS SLIGHTLY ABOVE WHAT
WAS PROVIDE UNDER LAST
REALIGNMENT. AFTER MUCH
DISCUSSION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
COUNTY PROBATION APARTMENTS.
AND COUNTIES WE REALIZE THAT
THAT MORE FUNDING WAS NEEDED
AND WE RAISE THE AMOUNT IN OUR
PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND WHICH IS I THINK
A SIGNIFICANT RECOGNITION. OF
YEAH BUT A PROVIDE THEM THE
RESOURCES TO BE SUCCESSFUL- AND
THEN SECONDARILY THE PROPOSAL
ISN'T CONDITIONED ON-
COMPETITIVE GRANT. OUR PROPOSAL
WAS STRUCTURED AND THAT WITH A
100% OF HOW MUCH COUNTY USE DJJ
IN THE PAST THREE YEARS AS THE
DISTRIBUTION BY COUNTY SO IT
WOULD BE CLEAR THAT THE
COUNTIES THAT WERE MOST
IMPACTED WE GET TE MOST
RESOURCES- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS A DIFFERENT
PREFERENCE AND LOOKING AT HOW
THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTING WERE OPEN THAT
CONVERSATION- BUT- JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ON SOME OF THE
ASPECTS OF OUR PROPOSAL. SO
THAT MONEY ONGOING OR ITS ONE
TIME FUNDING TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. ITS
ONGOING FINDING THAT RAMPS UP
AS- THE POPULATION RAMPS UP
LOCALLY. AND THEN STARTING IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WE
ADDED. AN ELEMENT OF GROWTH TO
THE FUNDING. TO JUST ONE BUT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BARELY PAYS
FOR ONE CLINICIAN. AND ONE
PSYCHOLOGIST. SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT YOU
DON'T HAVE THOSE RESOURCES THAT
THAT USE UP YOUR MONEY YOUR
BODY'S. SO THE INITIAL X. THAT
WE CONSIDER ALL DENTAL ONE OF
GOT MORE THINGS TO GET ON TO
SOMEONE. GO. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. KEROSENE DONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO IT SB A TWO FOR
THE ON THE COURT ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES. LOL. GOOD AFTERNOON ANY
DAILY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THIS
TRAILER BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
THE ASSESSMENT AND THE
COLLECTION OF AROUND TWENTY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RELATED
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AS OF JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MOST
OF THE FEES ARE CHARGED AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL DIRECTLY TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INTERACTING WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THEY GENERALLY
FALL WITHIN THREE CATEGORIES ON
ONE SIDE OF THE FEES FALL
WITHIN- THEY'RE RELATED TO
PROGRAM SO THAT ARE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION.
SUCH AS WORK RELEASE PROGRAMS
HOME DETENTION AND ELECTRONIC
MONITORING. A SECOND GROUPING
OF FEES RELATED TO BOOKINGS AND
ARRESTS AND THEN THE THIRD
GROUPING OF FEES RELATES TO
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ARE INDIGENT
DEFENSE REPRESENTATION. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE REVENUE LOSS
FROM THE ELIMINATION OF THE
FEES THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE COMMITTED
TO PROVIDING SIXTY FIVE MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
COUNTIES. BEGINNING AND- TWENTY
TWENTY THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAR. THANK
YOU THE PART OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ERIN EDWARDS
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
THAT WAS AGREED TO- AT LEAST A
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK AS PART OF
A THREE PARTY BUDGET DEAL- WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH STAFF TO
HAMMER OUT ALL OF THE DETAILS-
AT THIS POINT I THINK WE HAVE
AGREEMENT ON THE- PACKAGE OF
FEES THAT WOULD BE REPEALED ARE
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH STAFF
TO- RESOLVE. THE ISSUE OF-
EXACTLY HOW THE FUNDING BACK SO
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO COUNTIES-
IN TERMS OF THE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY WE HAVE AGREED TO
SET ASIDE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PURPOSE
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- AND
AGAIN JUST A MATTER OF SECONDS
HAMMERING OUT THE DETAILS
BEHIND THE ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE COMMENTS. MISTER
ROGERS. SO READING THE INTENT
LANGUAGE AT THE TOP OF THE
TRAILER BILL- IT I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING WE CAN ALL AGREE
ON THE NEED TO- DECRIMINALIZE
POVERTY. BUT LOOKING AT THE
FEES THAT ARE BEING REPEALED
HERE THE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
MEANS TESTED SO THOSE AREN'T
FEES THAT ARE BEING BORNE BY
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN POVERTY
ANYWAY. SO I DO EXPLAIN THAT
DICHOTOMY BECAUSE I WAS VERY
SURPRISED TO SEE THAT. IN OTHER
WORDS WHAT'S THE RATIONALE OF
REPEALING THE FEES IF THESE
AREN'T FEES THAT POOR PEOPLE
ARE PAYING ARE WE JUST
SUBSIDIZING THE PEOPLE. THAT
CAN AFFORD TO PAY THE FEES AND
ACTIVISTS. THIS CALL YOUR
JENNIFER ONE ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT WILL. OUR
UNDERSTAND I'M SORRY IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME- ARE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THESE WERE FEES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING THE
CLOSEST IMPACT TO- INDIVIDUALS
AND KIND OF THEIR DAILY IMPACTS
ON LIFE AND SO THESE WERE THE
ONES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED. FOR
THIS SPELL- WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN AND
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE TAKEN
ACTION OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS-
IN THE CRIMINAL FINANCIER
REUNITED TO ALLEVIATE BURDENS
ON INDIVIDUALS AND SO I WOULD
JUST OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THIS
IS KIND OF A NEXT STEP IN THAT
PROCESS. RIGHT WELL I MEAN
WOULD YOU DISAGREE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE FEATURE
APPEALING HERE ARE MEANS TESTED.
WE WOULD SO WE WOULD SAY THAT
IT IS IN THE LEGISLATURE CHOICE
IN TERMS OF WHAT. FEES FINES
EXCITER ARE ACCEPTABLE AS
PUNISHMENT FOR CRIMINAL
OFFENSES. ALL RIGHT WELCOME SON
OF JENNIFER CAN ANSWER THE
QUESTION OR. SO BRANDY STANDING
IS AT THE LIST OF FEES THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED HAVE
BEEN THE MOST IMPACTFUL TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE LIST INCLUDES- OF PUBLIC
DEFENDER FEES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR INDIGENT PEOPLE
SO EVEN. TO RECEIVE A PUBLIC
DEFENDER THERE IS SOME NOMINAL
FEE THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO
PAY I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT VIEW
IS OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD- BUT
THERE ARE FEES THAT ARE
ASSESSED OKAY BUT IF THE FEES
ARE MEANS TESTED. THEN IF
THEY'RE ATTEMPTED TO BE
ASSESSED AGAINST SOMEONE WHO IS
IMPOVERISHED THEY YOU WOULD
SHOW THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS AND THEREFORE NOT HAVE TO
PAY THE FEE AND MY CONCERN IS.
THAT BY ELIMINATING THE COURT'S
ABILITY TO CHARGE THESE FEES
WHAT WE'RE REALLY AT AND
PROVIDING SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO BACK FILL
THAT REVENUE WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING IS WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THE
PAYMENT OF THOSE FEES BY THE
PEOPLE THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
THEM. IT'S NOT MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT ALL OF THESE FEES ARE
ACTUALLY MEANS TESTED FOR
EXAMPLE CITY AND COUNTY BOOKING
FEES- JUST ASSESSED. FOR ANY
PERSON WHOSE- BOOKED INTO
CUSTODY SURE BUT THOSE ARE
FORTY THE FEES HERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF THEM THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE MEANS
TESTED SO OFTEN WHAT WHY ARE
WE- CONSIDERING ELIMINATING
THEM. BASED ON OUR STUDY- THESE
FEES HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
ANTI POVERTY ORGANIZATIONS OF
HAVE AS HAVING THE MOST IMPACT
ON THEIR- MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE SPECIFIC
PEAS FEES. ON THE MUCH. THE
LITTLEST WAS MUCH LONGER- AND
THESE WERE IDENTIFIED AS BEING
THE MOST KIND OF EVERY DAY- UP
COMMON FEES THAT ARE ASSESSED.
TO PEOPLE ENTERING THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM OKAY BUT I MEAN I THINK
WE'RE ON THE SAME TEAM HERE IN
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
POVERTY. IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S CRIMINALIZED. BUT THE
WAY YOU DO THAT IS TO FIGURE
OUT WHICH OF THESE FEES ARE
BEING PAID BY PEOPLE- THAT ARE
IMPOVERISHED IN MEANS TESTED
FEES BY DEFINITION I DON'T THEY
FALL INTO THAT CATEGORY SO. NOT
THAT'S MY CONFUSION. BETTER
FOLLOW UP. IS KIND OF A
RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT I MEAN
JUST TO MAKE THE POINT. WE HEAR
THE LEGISLATURE DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO APPROPRIATE FUNDS IN
THE NAME A FUTURE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURES RIGHT SO WE CAN
JUST PUT INTENT LANGUAGE CHEN.
TO OUR HEARTS CONTENT HERE AND
SAY IT'S OUR INTENT THAT EVERY
YEAR WE CAN APPROPRIATE. SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO BACK
FILL THE COURTS ON THIS REVENUE
LOSS BUT- HISTORY IS REPLETE
WITH OCCASIONS WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE EXPRESSED AN INTENT
TO DO THAT AND THEN FAILED TO
DO IT AND SO. I HAVE A FURTHER
CONCERN ABOUT THAT BECAUSE- OUR
COURTS AS WE KNOW ARE ALREADY
UNDER FUNDED AND OVERSTRESSED.
I PARTICULARLY IN THE RURAL
PARTS OF OUR STATE AND SO-
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I I'M
REALLY VERY WARY AT THIS. THANK
YOU THE COMMENTS. OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY YEAH I
MISINTERPRETED YOUR QUESTION SO
I SUPPORT THIS- BUT I SUPPORT
IF YOUR PEOPLE ARE POOR OR-
CAN'T AFFORD IT THE BIGGEST
RELIEF THIS IS THE BLANKET
EXEMPTION FOR PEOPLE SO YOU A
LOT OF FOLKS THAT ARE- FOR
INSTANCE. DRUNK DRIVERS THEY
ARE SENTENCED TO. HOME
DETENTION A RELEASE MEDICAL
BRACELET MONITORING. SO THAT
WOULD THE WITH THE BILL'S
PROPOSED THEY WOULD PAY NO FEES
CORRECT. IF I MAY UM ANNUALLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I THINK YOU WOULD NEED
TO LOOK SPECIFICALLY AT THE
OFFENSE THAT WAS AN INDIVIDUAL
IS CONVICTED OF SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IF YOU ARE USING I'M DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE THERE MAY
BE OTHER FEES AND CONDITIONS
THAT ARE ATTACHED TO FOR
EXAMPLE THE INTERLOCKING NISH
AND EXCITER OUT AND SO THAT IS
NOT ONE OF THE FEES THAT'S PART
OF THIS. PACKAGE AND SO YOU'D
WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SPECIFIC FEET- THE SPECIFIC
OFFENSES- THAT WERE- CHARGED
AND CONVICTED AND AN INDIVIDUAL
IS CONVICTED OF. THE SIXTIES
TRAILER BILL SO. IT'S A LOT OF
PAGES THAT'S LESSEN THE TRAILER
BILL TO GO THROUGH SO I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE THIS STUFF OUT
BECAUSE FOR INSTANCE A LOT OF
FOLKS COME DOWNTOWN TO HANG OUT
AND SOCIALIZE. SO INDIVIDUALS
GET DRUNK DRIVING IS HEADED
BACK TO THE SUBURBS SOLANO
FOLKS THAT THEN THE SUBURBS CAN
AFFORD TO PAY THESE FEES SO
LIKE I SAID I'M I'M JOHN THAT
DISTINCTION. FOR THE POOR AND
INDIGENT YEAH THEY SHOULDN'T
PAY WE GOTTA GIVE RELIEF AND
GET MY HAND UP BUT. FOR THOSE
FOLKS THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY.
DIED DIGEST IN THIS- BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE ALTERNATE
SYNCING PROGRAM FOR FOLKS- A
LOT OF THOSE FOLKS CAN WORK IT
OFF IT IT BUT NONPROFITS WE'VE-
THOSE OFFICIOUS REAL THINGS. SO
IT'S SO NO ONE CAN TELL ME
RIGHT NOW FOR DRUNK DRIVING
QUALIFIES INTO THAT SYSTEM IT'S
ON ANKLE BRACELET MONITORING
BECAUSE I GUESS THAT THE BOTTOM
LINE IF SOMEONE IS. SOMEONE HAS
TO PAY FOR THAT INCOME BRACELET
SO. I MEAN THIS THE REST THE
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR THIS.
IN MY SERVICE TO TAXPAYERS
FOLKS THAT ARE. WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE AND THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE
MINIMUM WAGE HELP CONTRIBUTE TO
IT. SO IN THE AVERAGE PERSON
THE AVERAGE AVERAGE. PERSON IF
EVERY CHEMICAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD COME THROUGH THAT THROUGH
A DRUNK DRIVING. SO HELP ME
HELP ME GET THERE ON THAT. SO
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- A
NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
OPERATED BY THE COUNTIES
COUNTIES HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY OPERATE THEM
ON AS WELL AS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY CHARGED A FEE AS WELL AS
HOW MUCH OF THE FEE WAS
CHARGED- SO WITH THE
ELIMINATION OF THESE FEES. AND
THE FACT THAT THEY CAN NO
LONGER BE COLLECTED THAT IS
WHAT OUR UNDERSTANDING BEHIND
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION COMING TO
AGREEMENT OF- PROVIDING SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE COUNTIES-
IN RECOGNITION OF THAT REVENUE
LOSS. NOW THAT THE INITIAL TO
PAY OFF THE THAT'S ONGOING
CORRECT. FIRST ONE TIME TO PAY
OFF THE FEES THE FEES ARE OWED
BACK FEES. THAT'S WHEN I HAVE A
DIRECT. I WOULD DEFER THAT
QUESTION TO FINANCE- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE ARE
STILL DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING RELATED TO THE EXACT
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDING.
YES THAT IS THE CASE THAT WE
ARE STILL WORKING WITH STAFF-
TO DETERMINE WHAT THE ACTUAL-
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY WILL BE-
AS WELL AS THE DURATION OF THE
FACTUAL. SO IT'S SO IT'S REALLY
IT'S A COMPLETE RIGHT NOW AND
WE'RE WE IN SESSION ON MONDAY.
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE A LOT OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS I THINK
LIKE I SAID I THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL I CAN ACCEPT TO HELP
PEOPLE BUT THEY'RE A LOT OF THE
DEVIL'S REALLY IN THE DETAILS.
ABOUT HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS.
NOW AS FAR AS VICTIM
RESTITUTION HAS THAT FULL THAT
GO AWAY. WE'RE THE FALL LINE
WITH THAT. IN OUR REVIEW OF
THAT SPECIFIC CODE SECTIONS
THAT ARE IMPACTED RESTITUTION
WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED BY THIS
TRAILER BILL. OKAY WE ALSO JUST
SO YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE COME IN
AND DO THESE THINGS WITH
SOMEONE THAT CAME IN IN THEIR
OWN WORK PROJECT WAS A
COMMANDER THERE AND THEY WERE
UNEMPLOYED YET THAT PERSON HAD
A TRUST FUND SO OBVIOUSLY SOME
OF THE TRUST FUND CAN AFFORD TO
PAY. THOSE FEES FOR DRUNKEN
DRIVING SO- THAT'S ONE THING I
MEAN LIKE SAID WE CAN GET THERE
WITH THOSE PEOPLE BUT THERE ARE
SOME FOLKS THAT CAMPAIGN SHOULD
PAY LOOK AT THE CELEBRITIES
THAT HAVE GOTTEN PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES THAT HAVE GOT ARRESTED
FOR DRUNK DRIVING. SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE RUB WHERE UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL THOSE FOLKS THAT
CAN AFFORD TO PAY. ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY. IS THAT
IS THAT CORRECT. THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE LOOKING WITH
EVERYONE WITH YOUR POOR OVER
THE RICH YOU'RE ON THE SAME
UNDER THIS BILL THIS TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL YOU'RE LOGGED IN
THE SAME GROUP. CORRECT. IT
WOULD ELIMINATE ACROSS THE
BOARD AND THE ABILITY TO ASSESS
AND COLLECT SO YES. OKAY THAT'S
MY BIG ISSUE WITH THAT AXE. AS
A NIGHT INSTEAD OF THE STATE.
WE SHOULD HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE
POOR THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT
BUT IF YOU CAN AFFORD IT BY
GOLLY SHOULD PAY. AND THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A MECHANISM FOR
THAT SO IF YOU GOT TO STILL
WORK ON THAT BILL. I SUGGEST
THE ADMINISTRATION AT LEAST
WORK ON THAT AND FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT BECAUSE-
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IF YOU'RE ON
A PROGRAM. YOU GO AND THEY DO
WORK ON FINANCIAL SHEET. AND
IT'S BASED ON ABILITY TO PAY OR
NOT PAY. BUT THERE ARE FOLKS
OUT THERE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
SOMETHING THAT DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
CABSI NUMBER GONNA GO TO OUR
LAST TRAILER BILL SB EIGHT TWO
SEVEN. I'M CANNABIS. SORT OF
BORED LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME
OKAY. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU SO THE CANNABIS
TRAILER BILL SB EIGHT TO SEVEN
REALLY HAS THREE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS TO IT. ON IT HAS A
TAX COMPONENT CHANGES RELATED
TO THE BSE SEA GRANT CROAK AND
CHANGES RELATED TO THE CANNABIS
CONTROL APPEAL PANEL. SO LET ME
FIRST TURN TO THE EXILE- SHOULD
BE TAXED RELATED CHANGES SO IN
ORDER TO CALCULATE THE RETAIL
EXCISE TAX. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THE
AVERAGE MARKET BETWEEN THE
WHOLESALE AND RETAIL PRICE OF
CANNABIS. CD TFA DETERMINES
WHETHER IT WILL ADJUST THE MARK
UP RATE EVERY SIX MONTHS ONCE
IN JANUARY AND ONCE IN JULY.
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE
DEPARTMENT FROM ADJUSTING THE
MARK UP RATE. THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE OCCUR INJANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IF DOING SO
RESULTS IN AN INCREASE IN THE
EXCISE TAX RATE. FUTURE
ADJUSTMENTS HOWEVER WOULD
REMAIN IN PLACE. ULTIMATELY
THIS WOULD EITHER HAVE NO
EFFECT ON THE TAX RATE WERE
TEMPORARILY REDUCE. IN ADDITION
THERE ARE ALSO CHANGES RELATED.
TO THE CULTIVATION TAX
CULTIVATION TAX RATE ANNUALLY
IN JANUARY TO ACCOUNT FOR
INFLATION THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THEM FROM MAKING THAT
ADJUSTMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. UNLESS IT IS TO ACCOUNT
FOR A NEGATIVE INFLATION RIGHT
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY UNLIKELY
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN A
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENT OF THE
RIGHT HOWEVER FUTURE
ADJUSTMENTS WOULD CONTINUE TO
TAKE PLACE THE BILL WOULD ALSO
LIMIT THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ADJUSTMENT TO JUST COVERING ONE
YEAR OF A VIOLATION. RATHER
THAN TO AS A RESULT THE
CULTIVATION TAX RATE WOULD
NEVER CATCH UP OR COMPENSATE
FOR THE MISSED ADJUSTMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND AN
ONGOING REDUCTION WOULD RESULT
WOULD RESULT. LET ME NOW TURN
TO THE CHANGES RELATED TO THE
PORT OF SPAIN COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. YES YOU SEE
PROVIDES GRANTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH.
EFFECTS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS
BSE C. FOR MAKING GRANTS TO ANY
LOCALS THAT HAVE BANNED
CULTIVATION. INCLUDING PERSONAL
CULTIVATION OR RETAIL SALES
THIS BILL WOULD INSTEAD
DISQUALIFIED ONLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THAT BAND BOTH
INDOOR AND OUTDOOR COMMERCIAL
CULTIVATION OR HAVE BANNED
RETAIL SALES. ACCORDINGLY BSE
C. COULD PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCALS THAT HAVE BANNED
PERSONAL CULTIVATION. ARE KNOWN
FORMALLY SPEAK ABOUT THE CHANGE
RELATED TO THE B. CANNABIS
APPEALS PANEL. BE CANNIBALISTIC
CONTROL APPEALS PANEL CONSISTS
OF TWO MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THREE MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR UNDER
CURRENT LAW MEMBERS MUST BE
FROM DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
HOWEVER UNDER THIS BILL THAT
RESTRICTION WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE IT.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS WE CAN
THIS ORDER. THE SCHOOL FINANCE
I APOLOGIZE. YEAH NOTHING
FURTHER FURTHER TO HAVE THANK
YOU. OKAY MISTER MONTE. ALL
RIGHT ACT. TO THE L. A. L. I. I
JUST HAVE TO ASK. WHAT DOES
THIS HAVE TO DO WITH THE BUDGET.
ALL THIS IS- THIS HAS TO DO
WITH IMPLEMENTING THE ARMS
TAXES- THAT ARE ASSUMED IN A
**** BUDGET SO THIS IS
BASICALLY. IMPLEMENTING SOME
TAX CHANGES- THAT ARE A PART OF
THE OVERALL BUDGET PACKAGE OKAY.
SO I'M NOT FOR THE RECORD I
AGREE WITH MOST OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THIS BILL ACTUALLY
BUT- IT'S UNUSUALLY BLATANT IN
THE FACT THAT IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE BUDGET USUALLY WE
AT LEAST THROW IN OUR
PREPARATION OR TWO AS A TOKEN
SO THAT WE COULD WAVE OUR HANDS
AND SAY IT'S A BUDGET BILL. BY
YOUR ARGUMENT WE SHOULDN'T EVEN
HAVE A COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION BECAUSE WELL ALL OF
THAT SHOULD GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE INSTEAD OF
THROUGH THE POLICY COMMITTEE
AND THE SHAME OF IT IS. THERE'S
NO NEED FOR THIS TO BE A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY A TWO THIRDS BILL
BECAUSE IT CHANGES A U. MA. AT
THE END AS YOU KNOW A POLICY
THAT THE ONLY ADVANTAGE OF
HAVING SOMETHING BE A BUDGET
BILL THIS SO THAT IT CAN TAKE
IMMEDIATE EFFECT WITHOUT A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IT'S GOING TO BE A
TWO THIRDS BILL ANYWAY SO THIS
THIS BILL SHOULD HAVE GONE
THROUGH POLICY COMMITTEE- AND
I'M I'M- I'M SORRY THAT IT DID
NOT- ANOTHER QUESTION IF YOU
WERE. TESTIFYING ABOUT THE
CHANGES TO THE CANNABIS CONTROL
APPEALS PANELS. START WHAT'S
THE RATIONALE FOR PUTTING
DIFFERENT RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS. ON A BOARD
MEMBERS THAT ARE POINTED IN BY
DIFFERENT BODIES. I WOULD HAVE
TO DEFER THAT QUESTION AS TO
WHAT THE- THE ORIGINAL TENT WAS
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE ORIGINAL
TIME WAS BUT- I WOULD DEFER THE
QUESTION TO STAFF AS TO WHAT
THE INTENT OF THE CURRENT
CHANGES ARE YOU'RE ASKING US TO
VOTE YES ON IT. AND I'M ASKING
YOU WHY THIS IS A GOOD IDEA.
EDIT THISIS A LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL AND MY AND BELIEVE MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROBLEM
TRYING TO BE SOLVED HERE IS
THAT- THERE. THERE ARE TWO
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THREE MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR- AND
THERE MAY BE AN APPOINTMENT.
ADD TO THAT- PANEL- FROM ONE OF
THE SAME COUNTY IS AN
APPOINTMENT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
ALREADY APPOINTED SO I THINK
WHERE IT'S TRYING TO SOLVE FOR
THAT ISSUE. WELL JUST TO SAY
THAT WE'VE GOT FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT WOULD BE OVERLY DIFFICULT.
TO FIND FIVE. BOARD MEMBERS
FROM DIFFERENT COUNTIES. IT'S
STILL HAVE 90% OF COUNTIES ON
REPRESENTED ON THAT BOARD SO-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
OUGHT TO BE CHANGED BUT THANK
YOU FOR THE RESPONSE. THANK YOU
YOUR COMMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE.
PROGRESSING THAT WE ARE NOW THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION. WE'RE
GONNA ASK ANYBODY WHO HAS
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM- FORTY TO
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. THE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOU HAVE A
MINUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON AND-
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE BRIAN
WHITE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF PERSONALIZED
LEARNING SERVICES IN SCHOOLS-
WE ARE A NETWORK OF EIGHTY FIVE
PERSONALIZED PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH OVER SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS THROUGHOUT
STATE THE ALSO KNOWN AS A PLUS
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON SB EIGHT
TWENTY. EIGHT PLUS HAS NOTHING
AGAINST THE HOLD HARMLESS
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED IN SB
NINETY EIGHT AND THE FOLLOW UP
CLEAN A BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
LIMITED PATHWAY FOR FUNDING IN
ROAMING GROWTH FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS HOWEVER WHAT WE
TAKE EXCEPTION TO AND ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO HIS DEAL
LAST PROVISION IN SB EIGHT
TWENTY THAT WOULD UNNECESSARILY
EXCLUDE ALL NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR. THE LANGUAGE
PRESENTS SERIOUS EQUITY ISSUES
AND HIRES A VERY STUDENTS WHO
ARE ALREADY FACING SIGNIFICANT
DISADVANTAGES INCLUDING LOW
INCOME AND MINORITY STUDENTS
DESERVE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION JUST LIKE ALL SCHOOL
CHILDREN ARE CURRENTLY IN
CLASSROOM BASED SETTINGS BUT
ARE CURRENTLY AND DISTANCE
LEARNING RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE THE
TYPES OF DISADVANTAGES THAT A
PLUS SERVICE IT SCHOOLS ARE IN
CONSTANT POSITION OF PLANT
GROWTH SO THEIR PLAN GROWTH
AVERAGES ABOUT 10220% ACROSS
ITS NETWORK REGARDLESS OF THE
CULPRIT PANDEMIC SO AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE CURRENT SITUATION THAT'S
ABOUT SCHOOLS AND TWO YEARS
THERE ARE NO SCHOOLS WERE TALK
ABOUT EXISTING SCHOOLS THAT
NEED TO BE FUNDED NOW. WE
THOUGHT WHEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM
SIGNED THE SB NINETY EIGHT BILL
THAT HE WOULD TALK ABOUT
FUNDING ALL TARGETED SOLUTIONS
FOR ALL STUDENTS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- SB EIGHT TWENTY
MISSES THE MARK AND AS A RESULT
IT'S GOING TO UNDER FUND A LOT
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE NON
CLASSROOM BASE SETTINGS WE WAS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT AS A
SOLUTION. FUND THE 10% GROWTH
THAT IS ALREADY AVERAGE FOR THE
SCHOOLS ON A TYPICAL SITUATION
THAT WOULD BE A COMPROMISE IN
OUR OPINION BUT THE NOT TO
EXCLUDE THEM FROM TOTAL FUNDING
IS REALLY JUST MISSING THE MARK
AND IT'S ONLY GOING TO MAKE THE
EDUCATION DISADVANTAGES EVEN
WIDER FOR NON CLASSROOM BASED
TUNES FOR THOSE REASONS WE.
OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS IT'S FIX
TO APPLY FOR THAT MANY AMOUNT
GROWT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'LL SEE NO OTHER. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
TWO WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONES MODERATE ARE YOU THERE.
IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AFTER TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO AFTER THAT.
BUT IF YOU THE MOMENT FOR OUR
FIRST OUR COPIER YEAH THE WHAT
YOU START SEEING PEOPLE LINE UP
FEEL FREE TO START LETTING THEM
ON THANK YOU. YOUR REQUIREMENT
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JUST ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST
LINE.
THANK YOU AGAIN WE HAVE
ABOUT FIFTY THAT QUEUED UP
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MORE MOMENT
HERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE JUST NEED ONE MORE
MOMENT FOR THEIR QUEUE AN ERROR
FOR THE COMMON.
AND WEBER LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JESSICA BARCELONA
WITH THE WESTERN AND ARMAND
POVERTY AND WE ARE PART OF THE
FAMILY OVERFEED COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF. ADD THAT THE
TRAILER BILL TO REPEAL TWENTY
THREE CRIMINAL JUSTICE FEET. I
WANT- TODAY AT LIKE TEN AM
OFFER TO TESTIMONIAL THESE ARE
RECORDED PRERECORDED TO
FACILITATE THE PARTICIPATION OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED EXPERIENCES AND- COULD
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE CALL DUE
TO WORK AND THOUGHT IF IT'S
OKAY I WITH THE CHAIRPERSON
ACCOUNT AND MAY I PLEASE. HAVE
PLAYED THOSE- ONE MINUTE
TESTIMONIAL IN IN THE RECORDING
NOW. HOW MANY DO YOU HAVE
OBSERVER. I DID HAVE TO COME
DOWN FROM THE COALITION OKAY GO
AHEAD OKAY WE GOT. IN AND OUT
OF TOWN IN JAIL. HI MY NAME.
I'M ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS IN AND
OUT AND COUNTY JAIL BEHIND
ADDICTION AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND- ISLANDS AND ALL
KINDS. SO WHEN I WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO GET PREGNANT OR AND ALL
OF THE ISSUES- I WAS LEFT WITH
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
LEGAL DEBT. YOU KNOW ALL I
WANTED TO BE REALLY WILL GET
BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES
IDENTIFIED BAD- AND- I ENROLLED
IN HIGHER EDUCATION BECAUSE I
KNEW I WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AN
ADVANCED DEGREE WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE IN A SIGNIFICANT
WAY. I DID REALLY GOOD IN
SCHOOL- BUT- YOU KNOW THAT
YOU'RE NOT AND THAT WAS LIKE A
HUGE PSYCHOLOGICAL BURDEN BUT
THAT ALSO PRACTICALLY IT AWAY.
FROM LIKE A LOT OF OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSES BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
APPLY FOR WHEN I WAS IN GRAD
SCHOOL I AN'T GET THE
DIFFERENT POSITIONS LIKE- I
WOULD HAVE BEEN CONSTANTLY
WORKING ON YOU KNOW. AND THE
MORAL FITNESS AFFECT IT SO LIKE
YOU KNOW PROVING THAT I WAS
CHANGING MY LIFE BUT AND THE
LEGAL THAT I JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE MEANS TO MAKE IT
SIGNIFICANT. THAT IN OKAY.
FIRST AND EVEN LIKE YOU THANK.
OFF THE TABLE. NINETY BUCKLEY.
I'M BOB. YEAH THAT'S THE FOR
THE FIRST FOUR IF YOU COULD PUT
A ONE. GREAT I'M NOT A TECH AT
ONE NOW SECOND ONE IS I MET
ANGELIQUE. AND SHE WITH OF THAT
HEARING. THANK YOU. ANALOG. I
WONDER. HELP. OKAY I THE FIVE
YOU KNOW I CAN SCHOOL. YOU KNOW
I MEAN I DON'T LIKE THE I GET
THE CAR LIKE YOU KNOW. I BYE
BYE. ALL ON THEIR. LOOK OUT FOR
CUT. NOT THAT BODY CAN REALLY
HANDLE. AND YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT
RIGHT AND LANDSCAPING AND WE'RE
NOT YEAH. YEAH. BAKER YOU KNOW
THAT WILL DYE IT. THANK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU COVERED WHY A
ONE THAT'S WHY ZERO PLEASED
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHIANG
MAI MY AT DOC ALL ON THE OF THE
EPL OF CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR. AM I AM ALSO HERE TO
SHARE THE SUPPORT OF A HANDFUL
OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
REPEAL THESE EMPTY FEEDS ON
THEY INCLUDE AND NEW WAY OF
LIFE ALL OF ARE NINE. ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER I WOULD
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES INSIGHT
CENTER FOR COMMUNITY DIVIDE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT LEAGUE
SERVICES PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN POLICY LINK SAN
FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT. FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND USED AFTER
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NETWORK WIDE ONE RECORD FORTY
FIVE ONE FIVE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS W. WHAT UW ACT THE
LOCAL DURING NINE THIRTY ON
BEHALF OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED ACT WHILE. WE ARE
THOROUGHLY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
WORK ON AT EIGHT TWENTY IT'S A
GOOD STEP TOWARD ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE THEIR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS EIGHT DURING THE
PANDEMIC BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
MORE PROGRESS HE EXTEND THE
AMOUNT TIME. PROVIDERS ARE PAID
WHEN THEY'RE CLOSE. IT CRITICAL
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE AMOUNT
OF TIME I NEED TO GET CODED PAT
THE FULL RECOVERY PUREE WE'RE-
AND REALITIES ARE PROVIDERS
WILL BE LAST TO CLOSE DOWN THAN
ONE. WE ALSO REMAIN. ABOUT THE
FAMILY THE WAIVER BEING TIED TO
THE VEIL ABILITY OF FEDERAL
FUNDING AND SITUATIONS IN WHICH
A PROVIDERS COULD BE LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG. OVERNIGHT BAG
AND HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HAVE
CLOSED DOWN SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC AND WE ONLY
CONTINUE TO LOSE MORE MORE
PROVIDERS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CHALLENGES. AT THE HEART OF THE
COMMISSION EQUITY COALITION WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO HEAR IN
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AB TWO OH EIGHT EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AB TWELVE FIFTY
THREE. WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL
TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE REVENUE
SOURCE FOR THE STATE TO HELP
FUND THE CHANGES WE NEED TO
MEET NEW PEOPLE DEMOCRAT CUTS
DIGEST. THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NIGHT WILL PROVIDE FIFTY
SIX GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- GENE HEARST
I COULD GO ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
PACIFIC WE- ACCORDING SB ONE
FIFTEEN AND THE REALIGNMENT
BACKSTOP PROVISION. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
OF MY COLLEAGUES AT BAY COUNTY
HOPING BACKING OF ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE LOCAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT MEASURE.
SECOND HE THINKS HE IS ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF PROVISIONS
IN SB EIGHT FIFTEEN REGARDING
EXPANSION OF THE ASSESSMENT
APPEAL DEADLINE FOR COUNTY AND
THE ACCORDING TO CONDUCT. A
QUICK MINUTE FIELD HEARINGS
REMOTELY I DON'T FEEL LIKE IT'S
PREFERABLE THAT SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA
AND. BEEN TRAPPED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU EIGHT
COULD GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
JAKE MURPHY ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING TODAY ON SB EIGHT
TWENTY THE EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL- I HAVE REPORTED
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA OPPOSES
THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY AND LET
THE BILL AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
SECTION THIRTY ONE OF THE
MEASURE- SECTION THIRTY ONE WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIERON IN THE
HEARING TODAY. WITH COMMENTS BY
THE REMEMBER BLOOMS I'VE EVER
MCCARTY AND THE PHONE NUMBER
OBERNOLTE- WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT SECTION THIRTY ONE OF THIS
BILL CREATES AN UNNECESSARY NEW
CERTIFICATION PROCESS ACTUALLY
LEAD TO DELAYS IN THE APPROVAL
OF UC CAPITAL PROJECTS- WE
BELIEVE THAT UP FURTHER THAT-
ANY CHANGE OF THIS NATURE-
SHOULD BE GIVE A CALL
CONSIDERATION PROCESS THROUGH
THIS QUESTION AND CONSIDERATION.
IN A SEPARATE POLICY BILL. IT
WAS NOTED EARLIER. THAT THE-
REGION ALREADY HAVE A POLICY
THAT GOVERNS THAT AREA OF
CONTACT THE REJECTED OPTED THIS
POLICY BACK IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. IN ADDITION-
THE ASKED ME COLLECTIVE BARGAIN
AGREEMENT WHICH WAS RATIFIED.
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR- ALSO
INCLUDES IDENTICAL LANGUAGE
RELATIVE TO- PROHIBITION THAT
ENSURE THAT UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S NOT CONTRACT OUT
FOR SERVICES. IN THE WAY OF
REFERENCE IN THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IN FACT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW WHAT
TO ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS- CARLOS
MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND BUSINESS VISION
THAN EDUCATION WANTING TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS ABOUT BE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL SB EIGHT
TWENTY- BUT- WE DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS. I HAD DINED
AROUND OUTSIDE BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL- AND- THE IMPROVEMENT
THAT WE BE THE IT REALLY PAULA
THAT WOULD INTRODUCED BY THE-
AND ENACTED UNDER SB NINETY
EIGHT FOR SITE BASED CHARTERS-
HOWEVER WE REMAIN GRAVELY
CONCERNED WITH THE ELIMINATION
OF NON CLASSROOM BATES SCHOOLS
FROM. THE EIGHTY EIGHT GROWTH
FUNDING FRAMEWORK AT THAT DEAL
ACT THAT HAD PROPOSED AND JUST
TWO POINTS OF CLARIFICATION AT
NUMBER ONE ON EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH
FIVE THE DALLAS WILL LOOK AT
THE GYM WITH A PARTY TO THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS. AND AS MR COOPER
POINTED OUT THAT THE MORATORIUM
WAS RELATIVE Q. A NEW SCHOOL
NOT EXISTING- GROWING
INVOLVEMENT FOR EXISTING
SCHOOL. THAT WE DON'T.
NECESSARILY NEED A CONTINUITY
THERE BETWEEN- THE MORATORIUM
THAT FRAMEWORK- WE ALSO WANT TO
GET THE POCONO THINKING VERY
MUCH CAPTAIN BEACON THEATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I WANT FOUR PLEASED AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MIND YOUR GO
GARCIA I'M ON THE PART
COORDINATOR WITH THE ANNE
RECEIVER CALL AND CALLING
SUPPORT AND SUPPORT OR AT EIGHT
THREE IN THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
JUSTICE AS A FORMER YOUTH FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND I'M RETURNING
RESIDENTS RIVERSIDE COUNTY- I
DO HAVE FAITH. THAT COUNTIES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND PROBATION
CAN'T EXCEED AND PROVIDING THE
BEST THEIR RECEIPTS FOR THOSE
RETURNING AND THOSE WHO COME
AND COME COME IN CONTACT WITH
THE LAW OFFICE OF YOU JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE INVOLVED
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
A PROVIDED OPPORTUNITIES AND
FONG RESPONSE TO CULTURALLY
INFORMED YOUR DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES TO SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION. INTO
ADULTHOOD IT- THE CENTER AND
THE POINT. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT DAY THANK. THANK YOU RIDE
ONE HUNDRED GO OUT. YOUR CARE
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
TYPICALLY OCCUR DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB T. EIGHT FIFTEEN
IN PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AND OUR
MEMBERS SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL FLEXIBILITY TO THE USE
OF TRANSIT FUND THAT FLOW
THROUGH THE STATE TRANSIT
SYSTEMS A GOOD REPAIR PROGRAM.
THAT LANGUAGE RECOGNIZED THAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE FACING A
FISCAL CRISIS AND MIKE MARSHALL
MARSHALL ALL THE FUNDING
RESOURCES AT THEIR DISPOSAL
THEY BALK FURTHER SERVICE
REDUCTION WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR BELL FOR SERVING AS THE
CHAMPION OF THE MEASURE. AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I LOVE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE
BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE AND SB ONE
FIFTEEN PERTAINING TO THE
REALIGNMENT BACK FELL AS WELL
AS THE EXTENSION OF THE
DEADLINE AND AUTHORIZATION THAT
ASSESSMENT APPEALS REMOTELY S.
B. EIGHT FIFTEEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SICK PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN US ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING THIS
AFTERNOON IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT TO THREE THE LEGISLATURE
ALTERNATIVE TO CLOSE. AT THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND REALIGNMENT RESPONSIBILITY
COUNTIES AND THIS IS A VERY-
SENSITIVE AND IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY WE'VE SPENT
CONSIDERABLE TIME OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATING
REALIGNMENT REALIGNMENT
FRAMEWORK THAT OFFERS RESOURCES
PROTECTIONS AND FLEXIBILITY
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
LOCAL INNOVATION AND SERVICE
CAPACITY- IF INDEED THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINES THAT DJJ
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO BE. TO
COUNT WE IN FACT BELIEVE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
AS NEGOTIATED WITH COUNTY
GOVERNMENT OFFERS MOST PROMISE
FOR SUCCESS- I WOULD JUST
MENTION THAT ISN'T OUTLINED. IN
OUR COUNTY ASSOCIATIONS AB BY
SENT EARLY THIS WE HAVE
CONSIDERABLE FISCAL AND
OPERATIONAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
APPROACH OUTLINED IN SB EIGHT
TO THREE AND IT DOES NOT
INCORPORATE OUR INPUT AND
PERSPECTIVE- WE ARE EXTREMELY
UNCOMFORTABLE IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS FRAMEWORK
WHEN THERE IS A VERY LIMITED
TIME AVAILABLE TO NEGOTIATE
WHAT WE IMAGINE WOULD BE VERY
CONSIDERABLE CHANGES.
PARTICULARLY WHEN THE STAKES
ARE SO HIGH FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WE THEREFORE MUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
NOTEBOOK ON F. B. EIGHT TWO
THREE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ALIGN THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CAME WHEN DEAN ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR AND POLICY LINK
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER SB
EIGHT Q. THREE WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO CLOSE BJJ THE RIGHT
WAY BY SUPPORTING THE
LEGISLATURE ALL ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL AND NOT THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN- WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATORS PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT
INCLUDES MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCLUSION OF
COMMUNITY INPUT. INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACHES THAT
PRINTER PUBLIC HEALTH AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND PROTECTIONS
THAT KEEP YOU OUT OF ADULT
PRISON WORLD THE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THAT YOU SUPPORT AND
TAKE UP AB TWO ZERO EIGHT EIGHT
BONTA AND AB TWELVE FIFTY THREE
SANTIAGO FOR A VOTE BEFORE
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST. STATE
BUDGET CUTS AND BORROWING FROM
EXISTING REVENUE ARE NOT THE
ANSWER AS THEY WILL ONLY EXTEND
THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND LEAD
TO THOSE WITH THE LEAST- HAVING
TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE
CURRENT AREN'T QUITE THAT. THAT
OUR STATE IS FACING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JULIE COLIN FARRELL AND
I AM A LONG TIME PUBLIC SCHOOL
ADVOCATE I AM A PARENT ABOUT
FORMER OF THE STUDENT WAS
FORMALLY IN AN ONLINE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I'M ACTUALLY AN
EMPLOYEE OF A ONLINE CHARTER
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO FUND ALL KIDS. IN PUBLIC
COMES TO UNDERFUNDING CALLED
SPECIAL PANDEMIC OF THE
AMENDMENTS TO SP TWENTY CREATE
AN EQUITY ISSUE AS MENTIONED
EARLIER IF THEY PROHIBIT ANY
FUNDING FOR THE STUDENTS AT THE
LONG CLASSROOM BASED- SCHOOLS-
I RIGID COMMITTEE THE WILL BE
EXCLUSION OF NON QUESTION BE
SCHOOLS FOR MANY GROWTH
CALCULATIONS. YOUR SCHOOL THAT
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO REVOCATION
PROCEEDING OR SUBJECT TO AUDIT
PENALTIES FOR ATTENDANCE
ACCOUNTING PRIDE MARCH FIRST.
I'M THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU RIDE FOR
FOUR CALL. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-BRENDAN KILLING ON BEHALF OF
THAT VOICE THE MAMMOTH SB EIGHT
TWENTY CREATING AN EQUITY ISSUE
BY PROHIBITING ANY FUNDING FOR
NEW STUDENTS AT NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS NON
CLASSROOM BASED. SCHOOLS WILL
BE UNCONSTITUTIONALLY DEPRIVED
OF FUNDS GENERATED BY STUDENTS
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
AND THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WE URGE YOU TO ADDRESS
THIS INEQUITY BY DELETING THE
EXCLUSION OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOLS FROM GROWTH
CALCULATIONS FOR ANY SCHOOL
THAT IS NOT SUBJECT TO
REVOCATION PROCEEDING WERE
SUBJECT TO AUDIT PENALTIES FOR
ATTENDANCE ACCOUNTING PRIOR TO
MARCH ONE TWENTY TWENTY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU RAIMES SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARKUP
PRAYER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF TAXPAYER
ADVOCATES- TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
PROPERTY TAX AGENTS- WE WROTE
RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTEEN. MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
TO YOUR STAFF FOR ORGANIZING
THE MEETING NOT ONLY WITH YOUR
STAFF BUT OTHER STAFF- IN THE
SENATE AND IN THE ASSEMBLY ON
THIS MATTER WANT TO BRING TO.
THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION THAT-
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WERE
DESIGNED TO IN PART HELP- KIND
OF FIVE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER I WANT TO NOTE
HOWEVER THAT THE BILL GOES
FURTHER THAN THAT BY STATING
THAT THE MEASURE SEEKS TO
ENCOURAGE COUNTY BOARDS. TO
CONTINUE TO CONDUCT REMOTE
HEARINGS AND WE WOULD ASK YOU
THAT- THAT LANGUAGE BE STRUCK
AND PROVIDE AUTHORIZATION- OF
THOSE REMOTE HEARINGS ALSO AND
I THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY ON
PAGE TWENTY FIVE LINES TWENTY
EIGHT AND TWENTY NINE. THERE IS
A PROVISION THAT STATES HAVE A
COUNTY BOARD CONDUCTS A HEARING
REMOTELY IT SHALL ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF SECTION SIXTEEN. POINT FOUR
THANK YOU WHICH PROVIDES FOR A
PUBLIC HEARING WE THINK THAT- A.
VERMONT TO APPLY TO THE ENTIRE
DIVISION. THANK YOU NETWORK
WIDE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHIRKING AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS BRENDA
FLEMING REPRESENTING THE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION I MEAN BEGIN BY
THANKING ALL WHO HAVE PROVIDED
INPUT AND SUGGESTIONS REGARDING
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
REMOTE HEARING ON PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLICK ON IT WILL
NOT HEARINGS PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONDUCT. AN
APPEALS BOARD REMOTELY USING
ELECTRONIC MEANS JUST A THREE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS HAVE
BEEN COMPELLED TO CONTACT THEIR
PROCEEDINGS REMOTELY AFFECTED
APPEALS BOARD SHOULD ALSO HAVE
THE OPTION TO CONDUCT HEARINGS
REMOTELY HELLO WHERE SO MUCH OF
THE IN PERSON PROPERTIES THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN FOR GRANTED NOW
LONG WALK NO LONGER ADVISED
ABOUT. RESPONDING TO THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
A COOPERATING EXISTING
STATUTORY AUTHORITY YOUR
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS TO SB EIGHT FIFTEEN
INCORPORATED A LOT OF
INNOVATION ARE JUST THE FACTS
PROPOSED BILL LANGUAGE
PROVIDING SOME OF THE FACT
LANGUAGE AND ARTISTIC SECTION
FIFTEEN OH FOUR AND ADDING A
NEW SECTION SIXTEEN SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN FIFTY TWO DOLLARS. WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE TAX CUT ACT
QUICKLY BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WITH EXPECTING
CONVERTING WE WANT TO BE A PORT
OF IT'S POSSIBLE ASKING THAT
THE TECHNOLOGICALLY MAKE A FEW
CHANGES TO ENSURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE CANNOT BE INTERPRETED
AS A MANDATE FALL FIFTY
COUNTIES TO HOLD REMOTE HEARING
AND CANNOT BE INTERPRETED AS A
MANDATE FOR TAXPAYERS STATEWIDE
TO PARTICIPATE IN REMOTE
HEARINGS. WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
PROPERTY TAX. DMINISTRATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LARGE
BERMAN COUNTY ARE VERY GOOD. ON
THE THANK YOU. START NEXT CALL
YOU NEXT TO WHITE A PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DO. A LOT COLLEEN
BEHALF OF. MY FELLOW CALIFORNIA
NAY BLACK HEARING A BLACK
CHILDREN THE REST OF BLACK TO
CALL THE STATE COME. WILL NOT
PARENTS. UNION DELEGATE. AFTER
THE LEGISLATURE TO AND STATE
ROAD. TO REJECTED OPPOSE REBAY
AND AMENDMENTS THAT UNFAIRLY
EXCLUDED NON CLASSROOM BASED
STUDENTS SUCH AS MY CHILDREN IN
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL ALL HOLD
ARE CURRENTLY NON CLASSROOM
BASED THE PROHIBITION OF
FUNDING. TO NON QUESTION BEING
STUDENTS IS IN DIRECT
OPPOSITION TO OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND CIVIL
RIGHTS. AND AMENDMENTS BETTER
BALANCE NEED TO BE IN FAVOR OF
NOT DISCRIMINATING AGAINST THE
STUDENT AND PARENT THINKING
QUALITY WAYS TO EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN. NONTRADITIONAL EANS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FIFTY PLEASE GO OUT. GOOD
AFTERNOON BE WHITE WITH AT THE
ARE YOU ARE BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND THEN. ON AT
WALKED REALLY TO THE LONG CARE
AT HOME PROPOSAL DIFFICULT AT
THANK OTHER IN THE FACT OF THE
DISCUSS ABOUT LOOKING FOR THE
VARIOUS CONCERNS ON AT THE
EIGHT WE- THE WORK DONE IN
PROVIDING SOME RELIEF TO THE
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS BUT IT DOESN'T GO FAR
ENOUGH THE FOURTEEN DAY
PROVIDED IS JUST SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH. AND WHILE WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE FEES BEING
BOARDED IT MAKES THAT MUCH
HAPPIER PROVIDERS AND
CONTRACTORS ARE LIABLE FOR
THOSE FEES IF WE DON'T RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDING WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT REVENUE MEASURES
LIKE AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROCTER
AND EIGHTY TOP FIFTY THREE
COUNTY IAGO AND THEN FINALLY ON
SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON HOW
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS WHAT WE IN
VALUE THAT WE SHARED WITH AND
TO AS A OF THE IN THE CAR. WE
WERE TO MAKE SURE WE ARE YOU
KNOW TRY. UP SECTOR AND TO OUR
ARTICLES THANK YOU CAN. THANK
YOU RIGHT WHY THIRTY ONE. CALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE EXPO. K.
TO FINE LEADER NOW. PROVIDING
CALM. ON SB EIGHT. SIX FORTY.
THE FINANCIALLY NETWORK THIRD
TEACHERS STUDENTS ACROSS. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NINETY. AT
IN PART. WITH COUNTY OFFICES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND TEACHERS
LEADERS AND REACHED MORE THAN
THIRTEEN THOUSAND TEACHERS
LEADERS. AND HAS IMPACTED MORE
THAN EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS. WE ARE RECOGNIZED THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO LEARN AND UNDERSTAND
SCIENCE THAN NETWORK PROVIDES
ONLINE EXPERIENCES WITH HIGHLY
ENGAGING SCIENCE EXPLORATION.
AS CALLED FOR IN CALIFORNIA'S
NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKINGWITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE FUTURE TO
HOLD FUNDING CAN CONTINUE AND
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS CAN
CONTINUE TO UTILIZE AND BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE PROBATION CHEAP
IN OPPOSITION TO IT S. B. E.
TWENTY THREE ON BJJ
REALIGNMENT. DESPITE ARTICLE
AGREEMENT AS THE ENTITY THAT
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
IMPLEMENTING THIS REALIGNMENT
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY SEVERAL MEMBERS AND THE
HEARING TODAY. IT WAS NOT
WORKABLE AND CURRENTLY DRAFTED
AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
SERVICE DELIVERY AND INNOVATION
IN JUVENILE JUSTICE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. PARTICULARLY IN A
BUDGET CRISIS WE SHOULD NOT BE
DIVERTING THEM VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES TO BUILDING A NEW
DUPLICATIVE BUREAUCRACY AT THE
EXPENSE. OF DIRECT SERVICES TO
YOU. ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INFLATABLE FUNDING FOR THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL PROGRAMS.
THE BILL PLACES THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT ATTRACTING
ARE COLLECTED SUGGESTIONS AS TO
HOW TO SUCCESSFULLYINTEGRATE
THE SYSTEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND ACHIEVE THE DESIRED OUTCOME
TO HELP YOU CAN POP THE
PATHWAYS FOR WORK WHICH I KNOW
WE SHARE. OPERATIVES RECENTLY
MULTIPLE EACH THREE TODAY.
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU RIGHT
WHY FORTY CALL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE
RED TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SECTION
TEN OF SB EIGHT FIFTEEN- WHICH
PROVIDES PROGRAMMATIC
FLEXIBILITY FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RAIMES SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO TERM
NUMBERS- INTERNET CONSIDER
PRESENTING THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. REGARD TO SB EIGHT
TWENTY SIX TWENTY NINE THIS
BILL LANGUAGE AND THIS BILL
INCLUDES LANGUAGE ADDING WOULD
GOVERNOR THE BOARD TO GO OF THE
TO COLLEGE SYSTEM ONE BORDER
THERE TO MACHINE TO SERVE TO
STAY TWO YEAR STAGGERED TERMS.
TO THEIR FIRST YEAR CANNOT BUT
WILL THE STUDENT IN THEIR
SECOND YEAR CAN WE INTRODUCED
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA TO
PROVIDE THE FIRST YEAR STUDENT
WITH THE ABILITY TO VOTE IN
LINE WITH THE UC AND CSU
STUDENT REGIONS AND OTHER
RECENT LEGISLATIVE PRECEDENT.
THE BILL CUT COMPANY. TO
RESTRICTION PRODUCTIONS. IT
WILL TAKE OTHERS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE BE IT MAY. AND THE
STUDENT BOY IN THE BILL. WE
WENT IN ALLEGE PROCESS AND I'VE
BEEN. LEADING FRENCH TO THE
VOICE FROM THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. THANK YOU. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TERRA I'M
NOT A PARENT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I'M HOPING AT EIGHT
TWENTY REPUBLICAN MEETING AGAIN
FAMILIES WHO CHOOSE A NON
CLASSROOM BASED HARDER
ESPECIALLY DURING PUBLIC TIME
YOU ARE ELIMINATING BALLOT
OPTIONS DURING A PANDEMIC YOU
SHOULD BE FUNDING EVENLY AND
FAIRLY FUND SHOULD FOLLOW THE
STUDENT WHEREVER THEY GO.
PERIOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GERMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
THEIR AGREEMENT WITH THE
CHARTER SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT
CENTER I'M NOT CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO BE GROWTH CAP ON
FUNDING FOR NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS AND ALL ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS CHARTER ADVOCATES AND
ADD A COUPLE OF POINTS FIRST
I'LL NOTE THAT THE- ADOPTED
STATE BUDGET ALREADY
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
BY DENYING THEM ACCESS TO THE
BULK OF THE CALL WITH RELIEF
FUNDING THAT THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATED. WILL ALSO NOTE
THAT MOST OF THE FAMILIES
AFFECTED HERE AT A LOCAL THEIR
STUDENTS MANY MONTHS AGO AND
NOW ARE FINDING THEMSELVES IN
LATE AUGUST WITH LITTLE OR NO
OPTIONS TO COPE MANY OF THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED ARE ACADEMICALLY
STRUGGLING AND DISADVANTAGED
MEDICAL NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL SETTINGS AND
FRANKLY HAVE NO PLACE. LEFT TO
GO. FROM HELLO NOTE THAT
CURRENT. PROPOSAL PENDING THE
U. S. SENATE THAT WOULD
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL CO GOOD
FUNDING TO STATES. WOULD
EXCLUDE THOSE STATES THAT
DISCRIMINATE AND FUNDING
AGAINST CHARTER SCHOOLS SUCH
AS- SB EIGHT TWENTY WHAT DO
THANK YOU. YOU I'M EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE ON A AND I AM OPPOSITION
OF SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY AT
THAT LATE TO THE GROWTH FUNDING
ACTUALLY FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL I'M THE
PARENT OF A STUDENT WHO ATTENDS
THE LONG COST YOU A PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOL AS WELL AS
EMPLOYEE OF THAT GOAL. I WOULD
LIKE TO POINTOUT THAT OUR
SCHOOL DID NOT QUALIFY FOR PPP
FUNDING DUE TO HAVING MORE THAN
THE MAX NUMBER OF ALLOWABLE
EMPLOYEE. WE ARE CURRENTLY
SERVING APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS THAN WE
WERE ON FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH.
WE HAVE ALREADY COMMITTED TO
ENROLLING PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE
OF THE CURRENT BUDGET BILL
INCLUDES ABOUT SENATE BILL
NINETY EIGHT. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS WAITING TO
ENROLL. AFTER HAVING PROVIDED
OPEN ACCESS LEARNING PLATFORM
TO ANY STUDENT WORLDWIDE DURING
THE CALL THE PANDEMIC. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR NON AFTER BE
STUDENTS ACTUALLY ATTEND IN
PERSON CLASSES. AT OUR CAMPUSES
IN AVERAGE OF ONE TO FIVE DAYS
A WEEK. JUST BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
CLASSIFIED AS NON CLASSROOM
BASED DOES NOT MEAN THAT THERE
ARE NO CLASSROOMS OR LOCATION.
I URGE YOU TO FUND ALL
CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS EQUALLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY GLAZER. AT EIGHT
TWENTY AND AT. THANK I NEED YOU
KNOW THOSE THAT BALLING AND NOT
CRAFTED MADE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT WHAT ARE PLAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JENNIFER BECAUSE THE NUMBER
THE- FAMILY OF CHARTERS IN THE
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS AND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THOSE WHO WORKED ON AN
ANALYZE THESE BILLS SO CLOSE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK IT'S
MEMBER WEBER COOPER SB EIGHT
TWENTY IS NOT EQUITABLE KENAN
CLASSEN BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
THEN THERE'S- NOT CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOL DO TO. AND COSTLY
LEASES DESPITE THE TERM NON
CLASSROOM BASED AND FINALLY
PLEASE FUND THESE NON CLASSROOM
BASED GOALS FOR THE PLAN GROWTH
JEFF DID YOU DID DISTRICT AND
SITE BASED CHARTERS WILL BE
FUNDED FOR THIS NEXT YEAR
CURRENTLY ALL CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NON
CLASSROOM BASED. AND RIGHT NOW
EQUITY IS A MAJOR TOPIC IN THIS
NATION AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
MAKE IT RIGHT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE Y. NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR SEVEN.
MATTHEW WHEATLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE YOU DID MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN IMPROVEMENT OVER THE
LAST DECADE. THAT THE
RESOLUTION OF THE FEDERAL
LAWSUIT AND OTHERS THAT THE
FAMILY MAN COOPER MENTIONED THE
DJJ STAFF TO COME TO OFFER A
LEVEL OF SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING THAT IS UNMATCHED
IN QUALITY IN DEPTH. THEY'VE
BECOME A MODEL FOR THE NATION
THE AVAILABLE PROGRAMS OFFER
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU
INCLUDING FULLY ACCREDITED
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AWARD WINNING SEX
BEHAVIOR TREATMENT. MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
AGGRESSION TREATMENT VOCATIONAL
TRAINING IN COLLEGE PROGRAMS TO
SEE IF YOU HAVE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. COUNTY THERE SIMPLY
UNPREPARED TO HANDLE THE TYPE
WITH THE VENDORS CURRENTLY
HOUSED WITHIN DJJ. DESPITE THE
BEST EFFORTS EVEN IF AFFECTED
PROGRAMMING IS EVENTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED IT IS VERY LIKELY
TO BE BOTH EXPENSIVE AND
INCONSISTENTLY DELIVERED ACROSS
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY. SB TWENTY
THREE SHARED RESULT IN
DESPERATE CARE AND TREATMENT OF
JUVENILE DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY HAPPEN TO HAVE COMMITTED
THEIR CRIME. FOR THE LAST
DECADE YOU GET DEVELOP NEW
APPROACHES TO CORRECTIONS
CHANGE WITH THAT ADDRESS. AND
INTERACT WITH THE WITH. THE NEW
USED FOR. THE DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES CRISIS CENTER PLAN
AND CONTRA RIDDEN TEAM WITH
EMPLOYMENT. AND THE DJ PROVEN
TO YOU TRY YOUTH BEST CHANCE OF
SUCCESS FOR THE THREE. WE ARE.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY LINE ONE
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BRIAN
RIVAS ON BEHALF OF THE EDGE
TRUST WEST CALLING TO EXPRESS
THE CONCERN REGARDING DISTANCE
LEARNING IN SB TWENTY THE ED
TRAILER BILL- THE CONCERN
RELATES TO SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION. EIGHT HAVE
MANDATED A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES BUT IT
LEFT IT TO ELEAZAR TO DECIDE
HOW MANY OF THOSE MINUTES MUST
BE DELIVERED YOUR SCREEN
CONTENTS ARE ASYNCHRONOUS
CONSTRUCTION. WE THINK THANK IS
FAR SUPERIOR- STUDENTS LEARN
MUCH MORE WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS AND INTERACT LIVE
WITH TEACHERS AND OTHER
STUDENTS. WE THINK YOU CAN
REMEDY THAT BY ADOPTING A
MINIMUM STANDARD AND REQUIRING
ELEAZAR TO NOTIFY PARENTS OF
HOW MUCH EACH STUDENT WILL
RECEIVE EVEN THINKING OF
CONSTRUCTION BY GRADE LEVEL.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FOR TWO. HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE PRIESTS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF A NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER INTERNET STALKING
OF OPERATIONS. YOUR LOCAL OUR
TEACHERS AND STAFF ARE LOCAL
ARE GROPING A WOMAN AT THE
RESULT OF DOING THINGS RIGHT
AND COMES PRIMARILY FROM
STUDENT TRANSFERRED FROM LARGE
CORPORATE BUYERS PROGRAM NOT
SITE BASED PROGRAM. MOST OF OUR
MOST OF OUR GREAT OKAY EARLY IN
THE SPRING AND WITH SIGNIFICANT
UNPLANNED ALL CHARTER START
SMALL BUT WE SHOULD GO WITH
NATURAL IN THE FIBER HELPS. YOU
FEEL LIKE WE'VE PLAYED BY ALL
THE RULES STRUGGLE TO SCRIPTED
PROVIDE THAT FIRST ONE YEAR AS
WE STARTED OUT AND NOW YOU ARE
CHANGING THE RULES. IF YOU ARE
WILLING TO PROVIDE. FOR GROWTH
FUNDING FOR EVERY SCHOOL. LIKE
A THIRD LITTLE GRAY SHOULD BE
AMENDED TO ALLOW ALL TO.
SCHOOLS INCLUDING CLASS BASED.
AND THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF
OPERATE TO. OR ONE THAT WE-
PLAN THE GROWTH FOR EVERY
SCHOOL. ULTIMATELY FUNDS FOLLOW
THE- THAT'D BE A- PROMISE. ALL
HEALTH TAX. I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THAT THE PPP TINY FOR SMALL
SCHOOLS. TO ARGUE THAT IT IS AN
EQUITABLE TRADE FOR THE LOSS OF
GROWTH FUNDING SIMPLY WRONG. WE
NEED TO GROW TO PROVIDE WILL
NEED YOUR SUPPORT. TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU. MY FORTY NINE LINE
FOUR NINE THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF COLLEAGUES
WITH THE URBAN TOWNS CALIFORNIA
AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN REGARDS TO SB EIGHT
TO FOUR. IN RECOGNITION OF ALL
THE HARD WORK THAT HAS GONE
INTO SENATOR MITCHELL SB ONE
FORTY FOUR OF THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND NOW SB EIGHT TO FOUR
WE JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP AND COMMUNICATION
ON THE COMPLEX ISSUE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FEES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FINALIZE THE
LANGUAGE AND METHODOLOGY FOR
ALLOCATING THE SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BACK FILLED HER
LOCKED COUNTY REVENUES THAT
FUND IMPORTANT. PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
NINE ONE TWO NINE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI JENNIFER CATHLAMET IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL I WANT
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY BE AMENDED TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS INCLUDING
THOSE IN NON CLASSROOM BATES
CHARTER SCHOOL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU. WE HAVE Y.
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
HEATHER SCOTT I'M CALLING FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I'M CALLING TO
REQUEST AN AMENDMENT TO S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY ASKING THAT YOU
DELETE THE EXCLUSION OF NON
CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC SCHOOL-
AT A TIME AND DISTANCE LEARNING
IS THE PREFERRED AND MANDATED
WE TO TEACH STUDENTS. BOTH OF
US ATTENDING NON QUESTION BE
CHARTERS ARE ABLE TO EDUCATE
OUR CHILDREN WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION- OR THE MOUNTING
ISSUE THIRTY BRICK AND MORTAR
PUBLIC SCHOOL- WE ARE ABLE TO
DO SO BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
FUNDED IN THE PAST. BUT
UNFORTUNATELYWITH THE WAY THAT
WE ARE BEING- EXCLUDED FROM YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE EDUCATED IN
THE SAME WAY AND IT IS UNFAIR
TO OUR STUDENTS- WE ARE BEING
PUNISHED AND UNDERFUNDED FOR
THRIVING AT A TIME. WHEN WE
SHOULD BE REALLY FOCUSING ON
ALL KIDS BEING TAUGHT TO PLEASE
AMEND THE LANGUAGE. AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THANK YOU.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE TO EAT. HI THIS
IS AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM
CREEK STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER DEAL HERE
BEGIN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE REGARDING DJJ
REALIGNMENT. WE'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS GIVEN BY THE PARK-
I CURRENTLY DRAFTED SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE PLACES ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION OUR SUGGESTION TO
SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATE THE
SYSTEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE
MUST BE ABLE TO TAILOR PROGRAM
SERVICES CAPACITY AND DELIVERY
METHOD TO THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH LEADER. AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
SAN MATTEO COUNTY  WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AT EIGHT
FIFTEEN ECHOING THE COMMENTS
FROM YOU SEE EITHER URBAN
COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA. TO
SUPPORT THE ASSESSMENT APPEAL
BOARD DEADLINE EXTENSION AND
THE REMOTE. HEARING
AUTHORIZATION THANK YOU. WE ONE
NUMBER ONE HOW AND FIVE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LAW ONE TWO FIVE. HI
MY NAME IS JOE SUPPORT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I COME FROM A
FAMILY THAT YOU CATER SPREAD
ACROSS THE US I USED TO BRAG
THAT I LIVE IN THE STATE FAMOUS
FOR PROGRESSIVE. IN A BIG IN
EDUCATION BY DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST NON CLASSROOM BASED
SCHOOLS AND FUNDING CALIFORNIA
SEPARATELY STUCK IN AN
EDUCATIONAL MODEL FROM THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTIES. THAT IT THE
EXPERIENCE NEAR THEIR
LIMITATION PLEASE STAND WITH
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND WITH
THAT THE EDUCATIONAL IN THE
BASIN THE FORM OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS. FOR KIDS THAT
ARE ALWAYS SUPERVISED BY
CALIFORNIA CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHY
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SEVEN SIX. I AM A
PARENT FROM CALLING FROM MARIN
COUNTY I REQUEST THAT YOU
MANDATE EIGHT TWENTY TO CREATE
ALTER LANGUAGE FOR THE ALL NEW
CHARCOAL. INDEPENDENT STUDY AND
BY A WITHIN THEIR FIRST THREE
YEARS OPERATIONS ALLOWED TO
GROUND THAT THE PARENT OF A
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD WHO
STRUGGLED IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM CREE COVE IT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT MY
CHILD NOT BE DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ALLOWED TO GO TO OUR
SCHOOL CHOI THANK YOU. WE HAVE
Y. NUMBER NINE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NINE. HI I AM A
PARENT OF A CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN THE VOICES THAT HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR FAIR FUNDING FOR
GROWTH FOR ALL SCHOOLS AND ALL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. WE HAVE MY NUMBER. NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NINE
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
THE CONNECT THE CALL. ON BEHALF
OF LOCAL AND TOKEN CARE THE
CLIMB INSTALL BORDER THAT HE
SEVEN THE CAMPUS TREE BILLWILL
COME OUT NEXT THE PORTRAIT CARE
TAX THAT TOOK BUDGET COULD.
IMAGE OF DOCTOR CALL TAX PLAN
WOULD WORK AND WHY OF THE L. A.
LOT NUMBER PRINTED. TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY BUDGET THE SB
TWO DIVERT CORRECTIVE
CULTIVATION TAX WILL INCREASE
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO BE
AFFECTED. BUT STILL THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE. ONE THREE. HI MY
NAME IS THAT APPARENTLY BACK
FROM ALL MALES. ON MONDAY
CALLING IN TO- ATHLETIC ONE AT
EIGHT TWENTY- THE COMPANY NAME
AGAINST NON CLASSROOM CHARTER
SCHOOL- BE DELETED. ARM RIGHT
NOW. WE'RE IN A VERY HARD TIME.
NOT ONLY A COUNTRY BUT IF THEY-
AND I THAT EVERY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN FUNDING FALL THEM NO
MATTER TYPE OF FLOORING THAT
THEIR PARENTS. SEVENTH THANK
YOU FOR TAKING MY CALL. AND WE
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HOW AND ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. ONE FIVE
ONE. HE MELANIE CURTIS DEPUTY
CLERK TO THE KING COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. SPEAKING IN
FAVOR OF SB EIGHT FIFTEEN WITH
M. AMENDED AND AMENDMENTS AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE BOARD STATE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION WE
BELIEVE THAT WHILE REMOTE
HEARING SHOULD BE PERMITTED IN
ORDER FOR THE FOR THE BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD. THAT NO LANGUAGE
CREATING AN ANTI OR PROCEED
MANDATE SHOULD BE ADOPTED TIME
SHOULD HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CONDUCT HEARINGS IN THE MATTER
<c.green>EST SUITED TO THEIR CURRENT</c>
PHYSICAL AND TECHNICAL
RESOURCES THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE ONE FOUR TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GOING
BACK TO FOR THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. EKING IN
FAVOR OF SB EIGHT TO FORWARD
GUARDING CRIMINAL FEET. IN
BRIEF BILLS AFFORDED BY THE
DEBT FREE GAS COALITION WITH
OVER A HUNDRED MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ASKED TO HAVE
THEIR NAMES ARE READ INTO THE
RECORD TODAY. AS ACTION
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER. CHIRLA CENTER FOR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING. CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER COMMUNITY WORK
COURAGE CALIFORNIA AND DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A NUMBER FIVE PLEASE GOING
LINE NINE FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SUPER RAIL FROM THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER. WE SUPPORT SB. EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WE AGREED THAT IT
IS CRITICALLY IN FOR THE STATE
PROVIDE YOU CAN OVERSIGHT AGENT.
WE NEED THE PROTECTION THAT
OFFERS AGAINST TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT WE LIKE THE FACT
THAT IT OFFERS FLEXIBLE FUNDING
RECOGNIZING THAT COUNTIES ARE
DIFFERENT AND GIVING THEM THE
ABILITY TO DETERMINE HOW THEY
WILL MEET THE NEEDS OF THE DJJ
POPULATION. IN AN INCLUSIVE AND
FORWARD LOOKING WAY NOW WITH
THE TIME TO DO THIS THE
GOVERNOR'S JUNE FIFTEENTH
PROPOSAL WILL NOT GET US TO
WHERE THE GOVERNOR SAYS HE
WANTS TO GO WITH YOUTH JUSTICE.
THE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
REALIGNMENT UNDER SB EIGHTY ONE
ALSO DONE AT THE TRAILER BILL
AND. IT WORKED OUT PRETTY WELL
THANK YOU. EVERYONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN LINE AT
ONE ONE SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SHAKIRA COMES
WITH PARENTS FOR PARENTS CHOICE
AND I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT TWENTY- TIME AND
TIME AGAIN YOU GUYS GET MANY
MANY CALLS IN OPPOSITION OF
LEGISLATON THAT LEAVES OUT
FUNDING. FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL. I DIDN'T
REALLY WANT TO IMPRESS ON YOU
ALL TO LISTEN TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. WHO WILL. HOW DID
YOU WIN BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE WE
DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE YOUR VOTED OUT NEXT TIME
SO I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU LISTEN TO THE MANY
CALLS IN OPPOSITION TO THE-
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THEY HAVE ONE NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BLIND STICKER ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTEEN WHICH INCLUDES LANGUAGE
TO EXTEND THE DEADLINE CONCEPT
NOT APPEAL BOARDS TO RENDER
DECISIONS FROM JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ABOUT THE FORTY TWO
AT FIFTEEN APPEAL COURTS TO
CONDUCT REMOTE NINE GIVEN THE
ON GOING PANDEMIC AND CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FISCAL DISMISSING
EMPLOYEES. AND TAXPAYERS SAFETY
AND THE ADDED TIME IT'S TAKEN
TO RESOLVE TAX THE NEW BUT I
DON'T LIKE THAT CAME WITH THE
COUNTY MODERNIZE YOUR SYSTEMS
AND HELP ALLEVIATE BACK WHAT
APPEARANCE LAST WEEK I FELT
CONFIDENT EIGHT FIFTEEN THANK.
YOU IN LINE EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
CALL LINE EACH EIGHT. HI MY
NAME ESPANA ON BEHALF THE
ENTIRE CITIZENS JUST CALL TO.
LEND OUR SUPPORT ON SB EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE I'M A PART OF THE
DECADE JUSTICE COALITION WANTED
TO ASK A FEW ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAD ALREADY BUT HAVE NOT YET
BEEN LISTED BUT ARE PART OF THE
COALITION- DOES DEAN KIRK
JUSTICE. EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA. GROWING
GREATNESS. JUSTICE TO. LOCAL
ONE FORTY EIGHT. L. A. COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S UNION.
NEXTGEN CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. THE
REBOUND AND VOICES FOR PROGRESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
SIX ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARTHA SELLECK GOES A DEALS
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFONIANS TOGETHER MY
COMMENT IS SPECIFIC TO US
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY.
SENATE BILL NINETY EIGHT FAILED
TO SET MINIMUM STANDARDS
SPECIFIC TO SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION WE HAVE HEARD FROM
MANY PARENTS WHO HAVE CHILDREN
IN DIFFERENT GRADE LEVELS AND
WILL ALSO ATTEND DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS. THAT THERE CONTINUES
TO BE A GREAT DISPARITY
REGARDING THE AMOUNT OF
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION
PROVIDED WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
WE SAVE IT RIGHT SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS THANK GOODNESS INSTRUCTION
IT IS RECOMMENDED THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
ENACT A MINIMUM STANDARD OF AT
LEAST THREE HOURS I THANK
GOODNESS INSTRUCTION PER DAY.
WHAT THE ABILITY TO ADJUST. AS
APPROPRIATE FOR EARLY A GREAT.
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDED IS
LINE THE NOW FOR PROPOSED TO
STANDARDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE ONE ONE FIVE.
THANK YOU THIS IS JEFF NEAL OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES-
ALL WHO WANT TO LEND BY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR S. B. EIGHT ONE
FIVE AND THE- CLARIFICATION IT
MAKES THAT COUNTY. THANKS HILLS
BOARDS ARE ALLOWED TO MEET
REMOTELY WHICH MANY COUNTY
COURT CREATE AND IN ORDER TO
WORK THROUGH THE BACKLOG OF
CLAIMS THAT THEY ACCUMULATED
DURING THE- SHELTER IN PLACE
STATUS OF THE PANDEMIC IT'S
JUST AN EXTRA FEW MONTHS TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE THAT CLAYTON
SMITH CREATED WE SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. YEAH MY NUMBER.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
FRANK WITH NON ATTORNEY AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND FORMER YOUTH AND CARBURETED
DJJ IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE. AT A
TIME OF SOCIAL UNREST OVER
RACIAL INEQUALITY PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES CAUSED BY IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE BY. AND ECONOMIC
RECESSION CALIFORNIA MUST MAKE
WISE INVESTMENTS THAT PROMOTE
HEALTH AND RACIAL EQUITY
CRICKET BAT YOU SENATE TWENTY
THREE ACCOMPISHING ALL OF THE
THINGS THE GOVERNOR REAL I'M
APPALLED THE PLANS TO ADDRESS.
LIKE KEEPING CARE CLOSE TO HOME
AND ALLOW INFLEXIBILITY AND
LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION BUT GOES
FURTHER BY CONCENTRATING ALL OF
IT THANK YOU JEFF IS FUNCTIONS
INTO ONE SERVING AGENCIES. AND
ACCREDITING IS CURRENTLY
APPEALING THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO EFFECTIVELY SERVE YOUTH AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY NAMELY THE LACK OF
VISION LEADERSHIP EXPERTISE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CALIFORNIA'S
FRACTURE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. BY ESTABLISHING AN
OVERSIGHT ENTITY WHAT THE
RESEARCH DRIVEN HEALTH OKAY WE
CAN BETTER SUPPORT LOCAL
PROGRAMS ENSURE UNIFORM AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE TO YOUR
INSURER COMMUNITY INPUT AND
MAKE BEST USE OF CARE. STATE
FUNDS WE RACIAL IN A REAL LINE
ON THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
LINE NUMBER ONE HOW AND FIFTY.
PLEASE GO LINE WHY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY IS NICOLE MAY
BERMAN HOMES MOM OF THREE
FOREVER TEN YEAR READ IN THE
BEING CAL. OF COUNTY I'M ASKING
FOR TO SP EIGHT TWENTY TO
PROVIDE A FAIR FUNDING TO ALL
OF OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE IN NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HEARD HAVE A GOOD DAY EVERYONE.
THANK YOU YOU TOO. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE Y. NUMBER
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX THREE. THE TERM
NUMBERS PERSONAL RESPONSES
RICHARD OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ONE
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR S. B.
TWO FOUR AN ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM PRISONERS BECAUSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BANKING SANTIAGO
BOTH. TO GENERATE NEW REVENUE
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED UP THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
DO NOT INCLUDE ANY TYPE OF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEEN HIT THE
HARDEST DURING THIS PANDEMIC
I'VE EXPERIENCED THE GREATEST
RATE. OF JOB LOSS IN EMPLOYMENT
BUT LEAVING A DARK MANY
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF ALL THE
LAST TRAILER BILL YOU'LL BE
ALONG THE PROMISED THAT FURTHER
GOING TO BE POVERTY AND ALL THE
CHILDREN TO CONTINUE TO GO TO
GO HUNGRY. BRIDGE THE COMMITTED
A DOCTOR WEEKLY REPLACEMENT FOR
DOCUMENT WORKERS WHO HAVEN'T
LOST EMPLOYMENT OR EXPERIENCE A
REDUCTION IN HOURS DURING THE
PANDEMIC LEVINE ECONOMIC RELIEF
FOR UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES IF
YOU SAID IN THE LONG TECHNOLOGY
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. I'M
SAYING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FAILED TO RECOGNIZE. YEAH
CANNOT REMOVE CALIFORNIA BEHIND
YOU FOR ACTING. FROM. THE
TROUBLES. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
LINE ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU ALLOW ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAPTAIN LIVE
ORDER PRESIDENT OF APPS NAY
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
REPRESENTING YOU SERVICE
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF S. EIGHT
TWENTY. IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
THIS TWO YEAR SESSION YOU SEE
OUTSOURCING POLICY BEFORE YOU
HAD SIXTY AUTHOR. WITH VELVET
VETTED THREE POLICY COMMITTEES
TO FISCAL COMMITTEES AND
RECEIVED EIGHTY YES. UNLIKE ACA
FORTY. FIFTY LEAVES YOU SEE
AUTONOMY ON TOUCH. BUT LIKE THE
PREVAILING WAGE LAW LANGUAGE
CONDITIONS PUBLIC FUNDING OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION TO A STANDARD
OF OVERSIGHT. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WILL
PREVENT OUT OF. THE CUSTODIANS
COOKS GROUNDSKEEPERS AND
MAINTENANCE WORKERS WE
REPRESENT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
TO LINE ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS CLEARLY
DEMAND I AM- MOTHER UP THANK TO
SPEAK. AB EIGHT TWENTY THAT IT
WOULD BE AMENDED TO SUPPORT THE
FULL GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
I HAVE FOUR CHILDREN THAT I'M
HOME SCHOOLING- HERE THAT ARE
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AND
ARE DOING COLLEGE WORK ALREADY
AND TO THE- NONSENSICAL DO NOT
SUPPORT THE- NON. TRADITIONAL
AND NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
IN LINE ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BUT A
MINUTE WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AD CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE HE DID DID YOU
HAVE MONITOR DJJ FOR DECADES IN
OUR MOST RECENT RESEARCH WE
FOUND THAT DJJ MAINTAINS
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS PUTTING
YOUTH AT. RISK OF EXPOSURE TO
VIOLENCE ISOLATION AND ABUSE BY
STAFF IN PARTICULAR I'D LIKE TO
KNOW THAT PROGRAM OFFERING
COUNTY BY DJJ ARE RENDERED
INEFFECTIVE IN ITS PRISON LIKE
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING. ONE
MEASURE OF EFFECTIVENESS
RECIDIVISM AS NOTED TODAY IT
DISASTROUSLY HYATT DJJ WITH 75%
OF U. THREE ARRESTED FOLLOWING
THEIR STATE COMMITMENT HE GAVE
WILL DISTRICTS ALSO HAD A BIT
MORE OUTCOME. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN NOT A SINGLE USE
INCLUDED HIGH SCHOOL SCORED
PROFICIENT IN MATHEMATICS AND
ONLY. 8% SCORED PROFICIENT IN
LANGUAGE ARTS. LASTLY IT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE FAILED TO YOU NEED
TO BY YOU IF I DID. THAT
DOUBLED AT DJJ CAN MAN DO COURT.
ON THE FOR ALL AND DID. HE IN
ADDITION TO BENEFITS OF CLOSE
TO HOME PROGRAM. GIVE REASON DJ
TRY SENSITIVE. AND WITH.
REALIGN OUTLINED IN SB EIGHT
THREE THANK. MEXICO LA ONE
FORTY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
CHAIRMAN MEMBER AMY AND ON
BEHALF OF THE COW CANNABIS
ASSOCIATION AND INDIVIDUAL
CLIENTS THEM FARM KENNEKA AND
BARK AND TRUNK THE COURT SB
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN AMONG ITS
PROVISIONS THAT AT THIS MEASURE
THREE THAT THE ONE YOU'RE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
AUTHORITY TO INCREASE THE
EXISTING CANADA PARK THREE OF
THIS PROVISIONAL PROVIDED MUCH
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY AND STABILITY FOR THE
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY WHILE
ALSO ALLOWING THE INDUSTRY TO
FOCUS ON BROADER REFORM EFFORTS
AIMED AT BRINGING MORE
UNLICENSED OPERATORS INTO THE
COMPLIANCE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
COMPREHENSIVE TAX REFORM WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND CRITICALLY COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KATIE HARTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PTA APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
WORK ON THE BUDGET THIS YEAR TO
MITIGATE THE BUDGET CUTS
HOWEVER AT THE BUDGET IS
LARGELY RELIANT ON TO PEARLS
AND FEDERAL FUNDING THAT HAS
NOT YET MATERIALIZED- SO WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO PURSUE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES TO ATTRACT
BUDGET DEFICIT THANK YOU. NEXT
IN LINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
PAIGE MCKINNEY I'M WITH HUMBLE
CONCIERGE A CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT SERVING THE HOME
SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND
REPRESENTING OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND NON CLASSROOM THE
STUDENTS I'M CALLING TO ASK FOR
AMENDMENTS TO SP EIGHT TWENTY
TO PROVIDE FAIR AND EQUITABLE
FUNDING FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT LINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TRISTON
BROWN OF CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR SAFEGUARDING OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION DOLLARS AT A
TIME WHEN WE NEED MORE THAN
EVER TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS SAFE
THIS PANDEMIC THE TEMPORARY BAN
ON NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
PROGRAMS BASED ON DISMAL
OUTCOMES FROM SOME OF THE
LARGEST PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
IT'S BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR A
GREAT YEAR. WE RECOGNIZE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ALREADY
GROWING PRIOR THE PANDEMIC WILL
CONTINUE TO GET FUNDING BUT
APPRECIATE SAVING FUNDING FROM
ORGANIZATIONS AND MAY SEE THIS
PANDEMIC IS AN OPPORTUNE TO
GROW TAKES OF EVERY OTHER
STUDENTS CURRENTLY STRUGGLING.
ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW WE'VE A
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL
LACK RESOURCES TO REOPEN SAFELY
DEALING WHAT WIDER ACHIEVEMENT
GAP SINCE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS LACK TOOLS FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING SO WE MUST
CONSIDER AB TWELVE FIFTY THREE
MAYBE TWO ZERO EIGHT EIGHT
BRING REAL REVENUE TO THE STATE
BUT WE HAVE TO BUDGETARY.
CATASTROPHE THANKS SO MUCH.
NEXT TO THE LINE ONE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND HAPPY WITH PUBLIC. ADVOCATE
THE NUMBER OF THE EQUITY
COALITION ON EDGE TRAIL BILL
AND EIGHT. WE ARE THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT PROPOSED
CHANGE TO THE AUDIT GUIDE BUT
TO DRAMATICALLY LIMIT THE SCOPE
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AUDIT
AND GREATLY REDUCE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN DISTANCE LEARNING THAT WERE
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR IN THE JUNE BUDGET. HE
SAID THAT THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANNED BUDGET
OVERSEE. FOR PARENTS AND THE
ANNUAL UPDATE TEMPLATE FOR BE
REVIVED TO ALIGNED THE LEARNING.
PLAN AT THIS. WE REQUEST THE
COURT IS BEING PLAYING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE TEMPLATE AND
INSTRUCTIONS BOTH THE BUDGET
OVERVIEW IN THE ANNUAL UP.
FURTHER WE RECOMMEND EXTENDING
THE TIME FRAME TO REVISE THE
BUDGET OVERVIEW TEMPLATE UNTIL
OCTOBER FIFTEENTH. TO ABOUT THE
VISION TIME TO CONSULT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. LASTLY TECHNICAL
ADDED THE REQUIRED TO THE
BUDGET OVER FOR PARENTS. OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN. TO REFLECT THE TIMING OF
ADOPTION IN ADDITION TO
INTEGRATING IT WITH THE
LEARNING CONTINUITY PLAN.
PLEASE REFER TO THE EQUITY
COALITION LETTER TO BE
SUBMITTED TODAY FOR A.
RECOMMENDED TECHNICAL AT IT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY ONE SEVENTY TWO LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
COMMUNICATE MADE PHONE CONTACT
WITH PERFECT UNION IS STRONG
CORD SB EIGHT SEVEN. UNION IS
THAT INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANY BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT PROVIDE HIGHWAY UNION JOB
WITH BETTER THE OF THE- SB
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD HALT
CANNABIS PACKED HIKES AND
PROVIDE RELIEF TO THE GOAL
COMPANIES JUGGLING TO DEPRIVE.
DURING UP ON PRESIDENT PANDEMIC
AND PERVASIVE ILLICIT CANADA
FAILED WE ARE HERE AYE VOTE ON
THAT AT THE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. NEXT WE GO TO LINE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
JERRY MEMBERS JOSHUA SHAW WITH
SHAW YOUR INTO ELTERN LANG
BEHALF OF OUR PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCY CLIENTS INCLUDING. THE
SAN FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY CALTRAIN
THE SAN MATTEO TRANSIT DISTRICT
AND SANTA MONICA'S BIG BLUE BUS
WHICH ALL THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR INCLUDING IN ADMINISTRATION
FOR CONSIDERING THE PROVISION
IN SB EIGHT FIFTEEN DISCUSSED
EARLIER BY THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION'S MICHAEL
PIMENTEL AN ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY'S MORE
ATOP PROVIDING. TEMPORARY
FLEXIBILITY FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO SPEND SOME STATE
GRANT FUNDS. ON THE OPERATING
OR CAPITAL EXPENDITURES NEEDED
TO MAINTAIN THE BOTH VITAL
TRANSIT SERVICES DURING THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES STILL FACE HUGE FISCAL
CRISIS BUT EVERY LITTLE. BIT
HELPS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEXICO TO LINE TWENTY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS AUDREY YOU WERE SENT I
AM A HOME SCHOOLER WITH A NON
CLASSROOM THE CHARTER SCHOOL IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I AM ASKING
YOU TO AMEND SB EIGHT TWENTY TO
PROVIDE CARE FUNDING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. INCLUDING
THOSE LIKE MY CHILDREN WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN COST YOUR BEACH
CHARTER SCHOOL FUNDING SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT TO
UTILIZE UP ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LAURA WARD AND I'M
AND SILVER BOTTLE CORNIA I'M A
PARENT OF TWO STUDENTS ENROLLED
IN NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL THIS EDUCATIONAL MODEL
WORKS AND IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER IN THIS KIND OF
DISTANCE LEARNING TO KIND OF IT
THE FREEZING OF FUNDING TO THE
SCHOOLS IS UNFAIR AND
SHORTSIGHTED. PLEASE AMEND SB
EIGHT TWO ZERO TO MAKE FUNDING
EQUITABLE FOR ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. MEXICO
TO LINE A ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME. AT THE
CHARTER COMMISSION BUT THAT
KIND OF ME AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
MY KIDS HAVE BEEN DENIED OVER
HALF OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THIS SCHOOL YEAR
THE STATE BUDGET FUNDS NEED TO
INCLUDE ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WITHOUT DISCRIMINATION THE FUND
SHOULD FOLLOW THE STUDENT.
PERIOD THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON%
THE NEXT LANGUAGE BECAUSE
UNITED TALENT OF BACHELOR WELL
WE APPRECIATE THE ATTEMPT TO
REMEDY THE AND EQUITY CANNOT BE
NINETY EIGHT SIX SIX COLLUDED
STORE FOR LAWFUL PROCESS OF
ALLOWING ALL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO RECEIVE A DAY FUNDS
FOR NEW STUDENTS. WHILE STILL
HOLDING HARMLESS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOR ANY LOSS AND GROWTH
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT SB
EIGHT TWENTY TRAILER BILL AND
IT'S AN EQUITABLE EXCLUSION OF
NON CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IS UNCONSCIONABLE
ILLOGICAL AND HER TWO THOUSAND
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY FALLING BEHIND THREE
CALLED. BIG SPRING LEARNING
LOTS OF THE MARCH SHUT DOWN
SHOULD NOT BE EXASPERATED BY
THIS EXCLUSION OF ALL BEING
NEEDED IMPROVEMENT TO EDUCATE
IN FRONT OF HIM PLEASE FIND
OKAY THAT WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
ALWAYS DONE AND SHOULD CONTINUE
TO DO SB EIGHT TWENTY IS NOT A
GOOD COMPROMISE. AS MCCARTY
SAID IT FAILED TO REPORTING ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WE MUST.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LAW ONE FIFTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ROB MAN OR A FROM
CHILDREN NOW. AND OF LIKE TO
SEARCH EIGHT MICE WITH A CO OF
EDUCATION EQUITY COALITION AND
PARTICULAR- CONCERNS AROUND ITS
ADOPTING MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
SYNCHRONOUS LEARNING BUT MOSTLY
I WANTED TO FOCUS TODAY ON ON A
SMALL CHANGE THAT HAS A
DRAMATIC IMPACT- THE
LEGISLATURE NOTES WITH THEM
ESTABLISH THE AUDIT GUIDE AS
THE TOOL TO PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR. EDUCATION
THIS NEXT YEAR ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT ISN'T PROVIDED BY THE
TRADITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM BECAUSE DATA IS NOT
AVAILABLE- THE CHANGES MADE IN
SENATE BILL. EIGHT WOULD. THE
AUDIT FOCUSING ON THINGS LIKE
LIVE. DALY INTERACTION ENSURING
THAT ALL STUDENTS RECEIVE
CONNECTIVITY AND DEVICES. I
SUREN THAT SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
IN ENGLISH LEARNERS RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THEY DESERVE AND
FINALLY ASSURING THAT STUDENTS
ARE LEARNING THEIR TIME THROUGH
CLIENTS THAT NOT MATTER THAT
THE VALUE THAT THE PAYMENT IS
VERIFIED IN SOME WAY ALL THESE
THINGS ARE RELYING ON THE AUDIT
GUIDE. TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
UNFORTUNATELY SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY WOULD ELIMINATE THAT
OVERSIGHT- WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ELIMINATE. THAT PORTION OF
SENATE BILL A TWENTY. NEXT WE
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
BROCCOLI ON BEHALF OF INTER
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION CAN
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT SB EIGHT
ONE FIVE. ASSEMBLY WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROVISIONS RIGHT
TO FLEXIBILITY PRIDE IN FUNDING
AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE
MENTIONED THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL. ONE TWENTY NINE
OPEN WHAT WHAT. NINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINES OPEN I. ONE POINT.
THANKS TO THE ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE ACCOMPLISHED
BILLION I AM THE POLICY
ADVOCATE CLINIC AT UT BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF LAW WHERE I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING FINES AND FEES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. AND I'M CALLING TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
POSED THAT SB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
AND ABILITY TO PAY STATE LAW
DOES REQUIRE ABILITY TO PAY
TERMINATION FOR SOME BUT NOT
ALL FEES. AND FOR THE PEOPLE
WHICH ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATION ARE REQUIRED THEY
OFTEN RARELY OCCUR IN OUR
HIGHLY DISCRETIONARY WITH MANY
JUDGES AND FINANCIAL HEARING
AUTHORS RELYING ON HIGHLY
SUBJECTIVE FACTORS LIKE THE
TYPE OF SHOE THE PERSON IS
WEARING. ABILITY TO PAY
PROCESSES PLACE THE HIGHBORN ON
INDIVIDUAL TO CHAU INABILITY TO
PAY AT THE END BY OFTEN ILL
FITTING STANDARDS OF LOW
INCOME. FURTHER DUE TO OVER
POLICING AND OVER TARGETING OF
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND BLACK A LOT NEXT
PEOPLE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL SYSTEM
AND SO THEY FACE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE FEES ESSENTIALLY CREATING
A REGRESSIVE TAX ON THESE
COMMUNITIES. IN SHORT RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT THERE IS NO
ECONOMICAL OR FAIR WAY TO
CHARGE FEES AND ANY SOLUTION
THAT DOES NOT COULD NOT
CONTEMPLATE FULL ELIMINATION
ONLY SHIFT DISCRETION AND
PERPETUATE THE EXISTING RACIAL
DISPARITIES. IN THE SYSTEM
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO. LINE
TWENTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JUSTIN GET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES JUST WANTED TO SHARE
SUPPORT FOR THAT DEAL IN THE
BACK THE LANGUAGE IN SB ONE
FIFTEEN ALSO WANNA THINK
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COUNTING ON THIS LANGUAGE AT
ITS PROVISIONS WILL ENSURE THAT
THE FUNDING GETS DISTRIBUTED TO
COUNTY THIS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT COUNTIES CAN PRESERVE
THE SAFETY NET. AND ALSO
PROVIDE ME THE CLARITY AROUND
THE COMPLIANCE WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS. RELATED TO THIS
FUNDING THANK YOU. NICE TO GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHANNON DANCE HOMESCHOOLING
PARENT ON EVERY AIRPORT SPACE
RESIDENT OF KERN COUNTY AS- ONE
OF MANY MILITARY FAMILIES THAT
HAVE LOST OVER HALF ARE FUNDING
THIS YEAR. HELLO NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL WE ARGUED
TO BE THE MAN SB EIGHT ZERO TO
PROVIDE FAIR FUNDING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS INCLUDING
THOSE IN NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL. PLEASE SUPPORT
YOUR MILITARY FAMILIES BY
MENDING. SB EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS SHANNON GARDNER CALLING
FROM EVERYTHING CAL. I'M
CALLING IN REGARDS TO SB EIGHT
TWENTY I'M ASKING THAT YOU GUYS
PLEASE AMEND THIS BILL TO
INCLUDE. FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS. THE FACT THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING TO CALL AND
ASK FOR EQUAL FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND ANY CLASS
AND CALIFORNIA. IS RIDICULOUS
IT'S JUST PUBLIC FUNDS GOING TO
PUBLIC STUDENTS THAT THEY
SHOULD ALL BE EQUAL THANK YOU.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWO OH TWO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREAS
STRANDED AS ON BEHALF OF MOXIE
AND CRESCO CANNABIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. AND MEXICO
LINE. SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FAMILY GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY WITH
THE PRICKLY SECTION FIFTY EIGHT
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT OF
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION
EXTENSION OF TIME OF THE TIME
FRAME TO USE THESE FUNDS AS
WELL AS THE AVAILABILITY OF
FUNDS FOR MUCH NEEDED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. WE ALSO
SUPPORT SECTION TO THE BILL
PROVIDING FOR FLEXIBILITY THE
WILLIAMS INSPECTION
REQUIREMENTS COVERT NINETEEN
SCHOOL CLOSURES WE SUPPORT
SECTION TWENTY SIX OF THE BILL
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
TECHNOLOGY BASED MATERIALS TO
INCLUDE HOT SPOTS AND LAPTOP
COMPUTERS. I TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY FOR OUR DISTANCE
LEARNING USE WE ALSO GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BUDGET STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP WHO HAVE WORKED ON
THE BILL AND WE BOTH ABOUT IN
THE OF THE AND OTHER ITEMS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
TIME. AT THE TIME THAN OTHERS
IN Q. THANK YOU REMOTE
OPERATORS SAYING NO ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- TO AS WELL AS ON THE PHONE
I JUST LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY
WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR- BUDGET
SUB SIX HERE AND WE WILL MOVE
TO ENSURE. THANK YOU.